ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव नाउ हम लाइव आ
चुके हैं एक मिनट में चेक कर लेता हूं
गाइस जस्ट वेट लेट मी चेक लेट मी चेक लेट
मी चेक गाइस लेट मी चेक एक बार मुझे बता
दीजिए एक बार जल्दी से बता दीजिए आप लोग
ऑडियो वीडियो सब एकदम टकाटक है
ना सब टकाटक है जल्दी बता दीजिए
एंड मैं यहां पर एक बार वेरीफाई कर लेता
हूं खुद से भी आप भी बता दीजिए
मुझे ऑडियो वीडियो एवरीथिंग गुड एवरीथिंग
गुड गाइस प्लीज लेट मी
नो ऑडियो क्लिय लाउड आ रही
है
लाउड ठीक
ओके चलिए बढ़िया थोड़ा सा माइक को मैं दूर
कर लेता हूं शायद ज्यादा ऑडियो आ रही होगी
चलिए बाकी सभी लोगों को आ जाने देते हैं
फिर आज का सेशन स्टार्ट करते हैं आज का
सेशन जो है वो काफी ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
होने वाला है डिफरेंट टॉपिक है बट कोई भी
इस सेशन को जो है वो अटेंड कर सकता है कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है अगर आपने प्रीवियस
वीडियोस नहीं भी देखें कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता
है ठीक है तो थोड़ी देर वेट करते हैं सबको
आ जाने देते हैं ठीक है एंड देन वी विल
स्टार्ट अभी सिर्फ 28 पीपल आर हियर ओनली
34 ओनली तो स्टार्ट करेंगे उसके पहले मैं
आपको कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट चीजें बता देता हूं
एज यूजुअल आप सबको पता ही है कि हमारी ये
जो है अ डिफ्रॉक साइबर सिक्योरिटी हमारी
कंपनी का
यह जो डेनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी के
स्टार्टअप कंपनी हम धीरे-धीरे ग्रो कर रहे
हैं किस तरीके से आपको भी आईडिया लग जाएगा
अगर आपको फ्यूचर में अपना खुद का
स्टार्टअप खोलना है तो एंड किस तरीके से
हम क्या-क्या चीजें कर रहे हैं कहां
कोलैबोरेट कर रहे हैं क्या चीजें ला रहे
हैं नई नई चीजें वह सब कुछ आपको इसी में
पता चलता जाएगा चलिए हां जी तो इसके साथ
ही आपको मैं यहां पर सिंपल सा एक और चीज
दिखा देता हूं
कि आप सबको हमारे
whatsapp2 जो है 4241 फॉलोअर्स हुए हैं
टोटल जो है आप 4241 लोग जुड़ चुके हैं
ऑलरेडी तो आप इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा अब
इसका लिंक जो है वो कहां मिलेगा साथ में
हमारा एक जो है डि फ्रक्स का बग हंटिंग का
ग्रुप है ठीक है यहां पे आपको मैं दिखा
देता हूं बग हंटिंग का एक ग्रुप है वो भी
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं ठीक है तो यह वाली
जो ग्रुप है यह बग हंटिंग के लिए स्पेशली
बनी हुई है यह जो ग्रुप है तो आप इस ग्रुप
को भी जो है आप जवाइन कर सकते हैं फिलहाल
के लिए इसका भी लिंक जो है आपको मिल जाएगा
अब ये लिंक्स कहां मिलेंगे यह भी मैं आपको
बता देता हूं सिंपल सा फंडा है ये हमारे
जो भी वीडियोस आते हैं
यहां पे लिंक्स मिल जाएंगे और ये लिंक्स
कहां पे होते हैं सिंपल आप हमारे किसी भी
लाइव सेक्शन के लाइव वीडियो में चले
जाइएगा सिंपल व व्यू योर चैनल पे अभी सभी
लोगों को आ जाने देते हैं देन स्टार्ट
करेंगे क्योंकि अभी तो 50 भी नहीं हुए जब
तक होंगे नहीं तब तक हम स्टार्ट करेंगे
नहीं तो यहां पे सिंपल सा कोई भी वीडियो
ओपन कर लीजिए लाइव वाली एंड आप सबको पता
ही है इसका डिस्क्रिप्शन यहां होता है
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आप आइएगा यहां इसको मोर
पे करिएगा क्लिक देन यहां पे आपको सारी
लिंक्स मिलते हैं इसमें ऊपर में ही आपको
यहां पे बग हंटर
whatsapp's इट ठीक है चलिए ये तो आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा साथ ही आपको पता ही होगा
कि अ
लिए तो गाइस अभी वेट कर रहे हैं कितने लोग
44 आ चुके हैं अभी तक 44 आए हैं थोड़े और
बचे हुए हैं उनको भी आ जाने देते हैं एंड
आज एज आप सबको पता होगा कि आज की जो क्लास
है उसमें हम स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं वर्डप्रेस
हंटिंग हम स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं वर्डप्रेस
हंटिंग अब ये वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग क्यों
जरूरी है मैं आपको इसका एक प्रॉपर रीजन भी
बता देता हूं आपको प्रॉपर सारा अ जो अ
रीजन है एग्जैक्ट रीजन कि भाई वर्डप्रेस
हंटिंग क्यों जरूरी है क्या यह वाकई काम
आएगा क्या हमारे लिए यह यूज़फुल है तो
बिल्कुल इसका सिंपल सा एक आंसर है कि यह
आपके लिए उतना ही यूज़फुल है जितना आपके
लिए बाकी अ जो वेबसाइट्स आप हंट करते हैं
जिस पे बग्स फाइंड करने के लिए जाते हैं
वो ठीक है तो अब यह वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग
मैंने क्यों लाया इसका एक बहुत बड़ा रीजन
यह है जो कि आपको
लप कीजिए यह फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट जो बग बाउंट की
क्लासेस आपकी चलती हैं गाइस मैं आपको सच
बता रहा हूं यह मैं थोड़ी देर बस वो कर
लेते
हैं पॉप अप चैट को पॉप आ पॉप आउट कर लेता
हूं मैं यहां पे 52 हो गए बहुत बढ़िया
बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया लेकिन 100 होने
वाले थे ना 100 का क्या हुआ 100 का तो तुम
लोग कभी कुछ करते ही नहीं हो चलो कोई बात
नहीं क्या कर सकते
हैं चलो कोई बात नहीं तो यहां पे इस बग
हंटिंग की सीरी सीरीज में आपको जो नॉलेज
मिल रही है अब क्या है ना कुछ बंदे मैसेज
आया था कुछ बंदों का सर हमें बग बाउंट की
क्लास लेनी है आपसे मैंने बोला क्या क्लास
लेनी है वेब पेन टेस्टिंग सीखनी है कुछ
हां वेब बोला सीखना है हमें बग माउंटी का
तो मैंने बोला कि क्यों सीखनी क्यों है
पैसे देके क्यों सीखनी है तो सर हमें
पर्सनल सीखना है मैंने फिर यही रिप्लाई
किया कि भाई पर्सनल हो या ग्रुप में हो
आपको जो डिफ्रॉक्ड पे जो बग बाउंट की
क्लासेस चल रही है वही मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा
सिंपल सा फंडा है जाके फ्री में सीख लो
क्या मतलब फालतू पैसे वेस्ट करने की जब
फ्री में मिल रही है बिना मतलब का क्या है
ना माइंडसेट होता है लोगों का पता है क्या
माइंडसेट होता है दिमाग में ये होता है कि
फ्री में मिल रहा है तो उसकी वैल्यू नहीं
है फ्री में मिल रहा है अरे भाई इसमें
थोड़ा कमी बताया होगा अरे भाई बहुत कुछ तो
बताया नहीं होगा बहुत कुछ तो छोड़ दिया
होगा ये सब कुछ दिमाग में चल रहा है मैं
आपको गारंटी देता हूं इस बग हंटिंग सीरीज
के जितने भी बग्स कवर किए गए हैं उन बग्स
को आप यहां से कवर करके एंड उसको
एक्सप्लोर करो खुद से अब तुम सोचोगे कि
भैया नहीं मुझे पूरा का पूरा चम्मच से ऐसे
निकाल के मुंह में खिला दो और फिर मैं बन
गया हंटर ये तो कभी नहीं होने वाला है कोई
भी ट्रेनर कोई भी आपको मेंटर आपका ऐसा कुछ
नहीं कर सकता कभी नहीं कर सकता है जब तक
आप अपनी एफर्ट नहीं डालोगे तो अगर आपने ये
देख लिया वो एफर्ट डाल दी है ना भाई उसके
बाद अगर तुमसे नहीं हो पा रहा या नहीं
मिले वनबिल या बक्स तब बोल बोलना ना अब
तुरंत हार मान जाओगे 2 महीने ती महीने छ
महीने में तो फिर कैसे चलेगा यहां सालों
साल हंटर्स लगे पड़े रहते हैं एक वैलिड
वर्क फाइंड फाइंड करने के लिए और वो जब
वैलिड वर्क फाइंड हो जाती है उसके बाद फिर
वो रुकते नहीं है वो चलते जाते हैं तो तो
ये आपकी मर्जी है ठीक है
चलिए चलिए ठीक है ये समझ में आ गया गॉट इट
चलिए तो अब अब जो है गाइ हम अपने टॉपिक पे
वापस से आ जाते हैं इसको मैं क्लोज कर
देता हूं एंड अब मैं आपको बताने वाला था
कि क्यों हम वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग को स्टार्ट
करने वाले हैं तो इसका रीजन जो है मैं
नहीं बताऊंगा
google2 में जून की ही बात कर रहा हूं
देयर आर ओवर 8 10 मिलियन वेबसाइट्स दैट
यूज वर्डप्रेस व्हिच इज 40 3.2 ऑफ ऑल
वेबसाइट्स ऑन इंटरनेट तुम समझ रहे हो इस
बात को कि 43.2 पर जितने भी लाइव
वेबसाइट्स है ना उसमें वर्डप्रेस पे काम
कर रहे हैं वर्डप्रेस पे वो अपना जो उनका
सीएमएस है कंटेंट मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम वो
वर्डप्रेस है तो सोचो वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग
कितनी जरूरी है अगर तुम वर्डप्रेस के अंदर
डीप घुस गए तो बहुत सारी प्रोग्राम्स हैं
बहुत सारी वेबसाइट्स हैं जिनकी जो डोमेन
जो वेबसाइट है वह वर्डप्रेस के ऊपर बनी
हुई है वर्डप्रेस के ऊपर काम कर रही है चल
रही है एंड
दैट्ची से करना पड़ेगा तो देखो वर्डप्रेस
जो वेबसाइट्स होती है ना इसका एक आपको मैं
थोड़ा सा अ पूरा क्रोनोलॉजी समझा देता हूं
कि यह किस तरह की वेबसाइट्स होती हैं किस
तरह का इसका जो सीएमएस है वो किस तरह का
होता है ये भी मैं आपको समझा देता हूं या
समझा दूंगा अभी ठीक है तो पहले क्या हो
जाता है ना इसका तो एक एडमिन पैनल होता है
वर्डप्रेस के अंदर में जब वर्डप्रेस
वेबसाइट पे आप विजिट करोगे तो उसका एक
एडमिन पैनल होता है एंड सिंपल सा जहां पे
आप एडमिन लॉगइन करके जाओगे तो डैशबोर्ड
होता है एडमिन पैनल या डैशबोर्ड इसका जो
होता है वो होता है ठीक है दूसरा जो होता
है वर्डप्रेस के अंदर में इसमें आपको
प्लगिंस मिलते हैं यानी कि डिफरेंट
डिफरेंट टास्क्स करने के लिए आपको प्लगिंस
दिए जाते हैं जैसे कोई भी टास्क करना है
अब व जैसे अब मान लो ये वेबसाइट है चलो
लेट्स विजिट टू fix.com मान लो ये वेबसाइट
है dex.com इसका ऊपर में एक हेडर है ठीक
है यहां पे आपको दिख रहा है ये हैड डर
यहां पे ये हेडर ये हेडर है ठीक है तो यह
टॉप हेडर हो गई यह हेडर हो गई और सबसे
नीचे जब आप आओगे तो यहां पे एक फुटर आपको
दिखेगा सबसे नीचे आप आओगे तो क्या दिखेगा
चलिए यहां पे मैं नीचे कर देता हूं यहां
पे नीचे में होता है एक फुटर होता है ठीक
है तो इस तरीके से हेडर एंड फुटर ये सारी
चीजें होती है अब ये हेडर फुटर बनाना है
आपको कस्टमाइज करना है तो इसके लिए आप
प्लगिंस भी यूज कर सकते हो थीम के साथ भी
आप कोड भी कर सकते हो ये आपकी मर्जी है
ठीक है बेसिकली वर्डप्रेस जो होती है जो
वर्डप्रेस आपकी है ये पीएचपी में बनी होती
है यानी कि पीएचपी लैंग्वेज जो है बैक एंड
में यूज हो रहा होता है एंड पीएचपी पे ये
पूरी की पूरी वेबसाइट बनी यानी कि अगर आप
पीएचपी लैंग्वेज जानते हैं पीएचपी में कोड
करना जानते हैं तो वर्डप्रेस की सारी जो
लेआउटस है सारी जो कस्टमाइजेशन है वह आप
पीएचपी में कोड करके भी कर सकते हैं बट अब
सब कोई पीएचपी तो नहीं जान सकता हर कोई
पीएचपी की नॉलेज नहीं रख सकता तो उसको
आसान बनाने के लिए क्या किया गया इसके
अंदर प्लगिंस
एंड थीम्स को को इंट्रोड्यूस किया गया
प्लगिंस एंड थीम्स को अब थीम्स क्या होते
हैं जो मेन आपका वेबसाइट लेआउट जिस पे
होता है वो आपके थीम हो गए जो वेबसाइट का
मेन लेआउट है जैसे कि अभी हमारी वेबसाइट
है de.com तो ये जो आपको सामने दिख रहा है
किस तरह का लेआउट किस तरह की चीजें ये
हमने एक थीम डाल रखी है इस वेबसाइट पे एंड
उस थीम में एक अलग-अलग कस्टमाइजेशन है
एडिटिंग है उसकी वजह से क्या है कि ये थीम
का इस तरह का कुछ लुक आता है एंड प्लगिंस
जो है ये होता है टू इंक्रीज द
फंक्शनैलिटी ऑफ द वेबसाइट तो यह अलग-अलग
फंक्शनैलिटीज को इंक्रीज करने के लिए
प्लगिंस का यूज किया जाता है ठीक है तो यह
मेन चीजें आपके वर्डप्रेस के अंदर में आती
है अब यहां पे जो प्लगिंस हैं प्लगिंस एंड
थीम्स हैं इनके जो ना वर्जंस हमेशा रेगुलर
फ्रीक्वेंसी पे अपडेट होते रहते हैं जो
डेवलपर्स होते हैं अपडेट करते हैं क्यों
क्योंकि ओल्ड प्लगिंस में जो ओल्ड प्लगिंस
होते
हैं यह वल्नरेबल होते
हैं वल्नरेबल होते हैं ओल्ड थीम्स होते
हैं यह वल्नरेबल होते हैं ठीक है तो
वल्नरेबल प्लगिंस एंड थीम्स के अंदर की जो
भी वल्नरेबल है उसको नेक्स्ट वर्जन में
लाके फिक्स कर दिया जाता है यह यूजुअल
प्रोसेस है जो भी बग फिक्सिंग का प्रोसेस
होता है किसी भी सॉफ्टवेयर या किसी भी
एप्लीकेशन में तो ये चीज की जाती है अब
मान लो हमारे पास कोई एक वर्डप्रेस
वेबसाइट है हम उसपे हंट कर रहे हैं उसपे
ट्राई कर रहे हैं वनरे बिलिटी फाइंड करने
का तो हमें ना अलग-अलग तरह की वनबिल फाइंड
करने की कोशिश करनी है अब वपस के अंदर ना
बहुत सारी एक्सप्लोइट्स जो है मार्केट में
ऑलरेडी वपस के अवेलेबल है अलग-अलग वर्जंस
के लिए वपस का जो करंट वर्जन है मैं आपको
यहां पे दिखा देता हूं मैं यहां पे वपस के
ऊपर चलता हूं लेट्स ओपन द वपस ठीक है सॉरी
ये wordpress.com मैंने ओपन कर लिया
wordpress.org पे आपको चलनी है जब आप
wordpress.org पे जाएंगे तो आप देखेंगे
यहां पे लेटेस्ट वर्जन जो है 6.5.5 है ठीक
है 6.5
5 ये वर्डप्रेस की वर्जन है अब मान लो एक
हम वर्डप्रेस की वेबसाइट निकालते हैं कोई
सी भी वेबसाइट निकालते हैं तो मुझे बताओ
आप लोग कि वर्डप्रेस की मुझे वेबसाइट
निकालनी है तो आप किस तरीके से फाइंड
करोगे कौन सी वर्डप्रेस की मतलब वर्डप्रेस
की वेबसाइट की मुझे लिस्ट चाहिए कैसे
फाइंड करोगे मुझे बताओ एवरीवन लेट मी
नो कुछ आईडिया बताओ वर्डप्रेस की वेबसाइट
मुझे फाइंड करनी है
google.cm इस तरह का पाथ होता है
डब्ल्यूपी हान एडमिन ये वाली लॉगिन पाथ
होती है वर्डप्रेस की ठीक है तो अब हम
क्या कर सकते हैं ना यहां पे कि क्या कर
सकते हैं इन यूआरएल यूआरएल के अंदर में
क्या होगा एंड यहां पे होगा डब्लू प हान
एडमिन इस तरीके से मुझे चाहिए कि
डब्ल्यूपी हान एडमिन हो यूआरएल के अंदर
में तो हमें भैया वो लिस्ट जो है वो निकाल
के दे दो कुछ इस तरीके का तो ये आप देख
सकते होंगे कि इस तरीके का हमें लिस्ट
यहां पे मिल यहां पे आ चुका है यहां पे अब
यहां पे अलग-अलग तरह की वेबसाइट्स आ रही
है यहां पे आप देखो डब्ल्यूपी हान एडमिन
डब्ल्यूपी हान एडमिन यहां पे एक और होता
है डब्लू प हान लॉगइन पीएपी यह भी होती है
w login.php तो हम यह भी कर सकते हैं इन
यूआरएल एंड w login.php अब जहां पे w पलग
पीएपी होगी ओबवियसली है वो वर्डप्रेस
वेबसाइट होगी तभी उसका एडमिन जो पैनल है
वो w login.php वाली पाथ पे एब्लिश है तो
चलिए जैसे मान लो हमारे पास यह वेब
वेबसाइट आ गई फट
forest.in चलिए तो हम इसको ओपन कर लेते
हैं तो आप देख सकते हैं फट forest.in ये
हमारी इसकी व एडमिन जो पैनल है लॉगिन पैनल
आ चुकी है अब हम इसको हटा के एंड यहां पे
फ्रूट आ जब कर लेंगे ओपन तो यह हमारी एक
वेबसाइट जो है ओपन हो जाएगी फ forest.in
ठीक है तो यह 100% वपस में है यह गारंटी
है हमारी अब इसको चेक करने के लिए कैसे
करेंगे तो हम यहां पे मैं
लाइजर तो यह वे पलाइज एक्सटेंशन जो है
टेक्नोलॉजी प्रोफाइलर करके एक एक्सटेंशन
है इसको आप इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा ऐड टू क्रम
करके काफी यूजफुल होता है वेबसाइट के
डिटेल्स देने के लिए ठीक है तो यहां पे जब
आप आएंगे तो इस पर राइट क्लिक करूंगा मैं
तो यहां पे आ रहा है यह
वपस 5.6.3 वर्जन यूज कर रहे हैं ठीक
है यह
5.6.3 यूज कर रहे हैं यहां पे वर्डप्रेस
का वर्जन ठीक है समझ में आ गया इन यरल
बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढिया
google2 की पूरी सीरीज बेसिक टू
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल है पूरी सीरीज सिर्फ उनके
लिए जो बिगिनर्स है जिनको रिसोर्सेस की
कमी है अफोर्ड नहीं कर सकते महंगी कोर्सेस
फ्री में सीखना चाहते हैं क्वालिटी के साथ
सीखना चाहते हैं बिल्कुल स्क्रैच से सीखना
चाहते हैं तो वो है ये ठीक है
सीरीज चलिए तो यहां पे हम फ for.in पे अब
ये हमारी वपस पे वेब हमारी भैया आ चुकी है
ठीक है ये तो आपको समझ में अब आ चुका होगा
चलिए अब यहां पे ना थीम्स होते हैं
प्लगिंस होते हैं अलग-अलग चीज होती है बट
अब हमें क्या करना है ना भैया हमें वलने
बिलिटी फाइंड करनी है ऐसी वेबसाइट्स के
अंदर में ऐसी वेबसाइट के अंदर हमें क्या
करना है लेबिलिटी फाइंड करना है तो चलिए
हम लाइव वेबसाइट पे आके लेबिलिटी फाइंड
करेंगे बिल्कुल करेंगे लाइव टारगेट पे
करेंगे जैसे ये भी एक लाइव टारगेट ही हो
गया हम इस पे भी आ जाएंगे बट उसके पहले
आपको कुछ चीजें बतानी बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी
है
सबसे
पहला एक और फाइल एक और यूटिलिटी जिस पे हम
लेबिलिटी को फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेंगे
जो कि काफी यूजफुल होता है वो है एक्सएमए
आरपीसी ड पीएपी फाइल एक्सए आरपीसी पीएपी
फाइल अब ये एक्सएमएल आरपीसी क्या होता है
देखो यहां पे एक्सएमएल आरपीसी जो होती है
यह एक रिमोट प्रोसीजर कॉल के लिए यूज किया
जाता है या एक तरह का यह एपीआई कॉल के लिए
एक तरह का यूज किया जाता है यानी कि इस
इसके थ्रू इसके थ्रू हम क्या कर सकते हैं
ना
कम्युनिकेट
एक्सटर्नल
एप्लीकेशंस
एप्लीकेशंस क
कम्युनिकेट विथ वर्डप्रेस
ठीक है तो इसके थ्रू क्या करता है कोई भी
एक्सटर्नल एप्लीकेशन है वो वर्डप्रेस से
कम्युनिकेट करता है इसलिए एक्सए आरपीसी ड
पीएपी जो है यह फाइल यूज होती है
वर्डप्रेस के अंदर में अब इस वर्डप्रेस
फाइल के अंदर ना कुछ इनबिल्ट वनबिल ज हैं
मतलब इसकी कुछ कोडिंग में ही ऐसे इश्यूज
पाए गए जिसके बाद ये रिकमेंड किया जाता है
कि xmlrpc.php आपकी वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट पे
इनेबल नहीं होना चाहिए डिसेबल्ड होना
चाहिए नहीं होना चाहिए डिसेबल्ड होना
चाहिए ठीक है बट क्या होता है कि बाय
डिफॉल्ट ये कई वेबसाइट्स में इनेबल पाया
जाता है बाय डिफॉल्ट क्या कई वेबसाइट पे
ये इनेबल पाया जाता है ठीक है बट ये एक
अच्छी प्रैक्टिस होती है कि इसको हमेशा
डिसेबल करके रखने का ऑलवेज डिसेबल करके
रखने का xmlrpc.php चलिए अब हम इसका एक
एग्जांपल देख लेते हैं हम os.com पे चलते
हैं यहां पे हमारी वेबसाइट ओपन हो चुकी है
अब di.com पे जाओगे स्लैश करोगे
xmlrpc.php यह जब हम ओपन करेंगे और एंटर
करेंगे तो यहां आ रहा है डिसेबल्ड जब हम
हमारी वेबसाइट पे जाते हैं तो यहां पे
यहां पे आ रहा है क्या डिसेबल्ड फू
forest.in पे चलते हैं यहां पे एंड अगेन
सेम
xmlrpc.php करते हैं और एंटर करते हैं और
फिर देखते हैं यहां
पे यहां पे क्या आ रहा है आरपीसी का
स्पेलिंग हमने गलत दिया आरसीपी दिख दिया
आरपीसी होगा यहां पे एक्सम आरपीसी पीएपी
और एंटर करते हैं एंड जसे अभी देखो जैसे
यहां पे मैंने जब किया ना एक्स आरपीसी
पीएपी यहां पे कोई बात नहीं ललित इट्स ल
इट्स ओके इट्स ओके कोई दिक्कत नहीं
सर मैंने डिक्स पप पे आपका कोर्स लिया है
बहुत मस्त है लव्ड इट चलो बहुत बढ़िया टेक
एक्स धन्यवाद आपके रिव्यू के लिए चलिए
अच्छी बात है तो यहां पे एक्सएमए आरपीसी
सर्वर एक्सेप्ट्स पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट ओनली
यहां पे लिखा आ रहा है यह जब लिखा है
डिसेबल्ड लिखा ना है इसका मतलब यहां पे
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी आपका इनेबल्ड है बट
क्योंकि हम इसको एक्सेस इसलिए नहीं कर पा
रहे बिकॉज़ ये पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट को
एक्सेप्ट करता है गेट रिक्वेस्ट नहीं
एक्सेप्ट करता है अभी जो हम इसको एक्सेस
कर रहे हैं ये गेट रिक्वेस्ट के थ्रू कर
रहे हैं या पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट के थ्रू कर
रहे हैं ये बताइए मुझे ये जो हम यूआरएल
ओपन कर रहे हैं यहां गेट रिक्वेस्ट जा रही
है या पोस्ट जा रही है जल्दी बताइए जल्दी
बताइए जल्दी बताइए देख लेते हैं भाई कितना
किसको नॉलेज है किसको किसको याद है यह गेट
रिक्वेस्ट है कि पोस्ट है एकदम ऑनेस्टली
और
पूरी ईमानदारी से
बताइए गेट है पोस्ट
है
अच्छा गेट है चलो ठीक है सब लोग गेट बोले
गलती से मैंने गेट बोल दिया लेकिन ठीक है
ऑलमोस्ट को पता होगा मेरे ख्याल से है ना
चलिए ये गेट रिक्वेस्ट है इसलिए हम यहां प
एक्सम आरपीसी को नहीं एक्सेस कर पा रहे
बिकॉज इट नीड्स पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट अब इसको
हम एक्सेस कैसे करेंगे अब बताओ मुझे पोस्ट
से एक्सेस करना है तो कैसे करेंगे मुझे
बताओ
जरा बताओ मुझे कोई अगर पोस्ट से करना हुआ
तो कैसे करेंगे
हम लेट मी नो
गाइस बिल्कुल बब शूट का यूज कर लेंगे या
कर्ल कमांड का भी यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है
ना हम वी कैन यूज कर्ल कमांड आल्सो हम
कर्ल कमांड का भी यूज करके पोस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट में मेंशन करके हम उसको यूज कर
सकते हैं या हम डायरेक्ट बॉब शूट का यूज
करके हम वहां से भी गेट को पोस्ट में चेंज
करके हम कर सकते हैं हमारी मर्जी है वो
ठीक है चलिए तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
इनेबल्ड है अब इसके इसके मैं कुछ
ड्रॉबैक्स वगैरह भी बताऊंगा आगे चलके आपको
ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेनी है वी विल डील विद
दैट आल्सो ठीक
है चलिए तो xmlrpc.php देखेंगे बाकी जो
हमने वनबिल पहले पढ़ी हैं इन क्लासेस में
जैसे कि मान लो हमने क्या पढ़ा था लॉन्ग
पासवर्ड डॉस अटैक हमने पढ़ा था वो भी हम
यहां पे ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं क्योंकि
वर्डप्रेस की वेबसाइट है वी कैन जस्ट
ट्राई इट आउट हम एक्सस ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हैं हम आईडी ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं हर एक
वनबिल हम ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं जो हम
चाहते हैं जो हमने सीखा है जो हम पढ़े हुए
हैं क्योंकि यह भी एक वेबसाइट ही है बस व
वर्डप्रेस सीएमएस पे है तो हम इसको ना
एक्सप्लोइट करने की कोशिश करेंगे उसी
तरीके से किस तरीके से वल्नरेबल प्लगिंस
फाइंड करने की कोशिश वल्नरेबल थीम्स फाइंड
करने की कोशिश वल्नरेबल थीम एंड प्लग कहां
मिलेगी जब उनके वर्जन ओल्ड होंगे पुराने
होंगे जिनमें कोई व बिलिटी पाई गई होगी तो
वहां से हम निकालने की कोशिश करेंगे ठीक
है भैया तो सबसे पहले हम एक वर्डप्रेस की
इंस्टॉलेशन कर लेते हैं हम अपना खुद का एक
वेबसाइट अभी के अभी तुरंत होस्ट कर लेते
हैं 5 मिनट का टाइम मेरे ख्याल से लगेगा
होस्ट करें अभी का अभी खुद का वर्डप्रेस
से खुद का वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट जल्दी
बताइए कैन वी
डू क्योंकि हमें करना ही पड़ेगा कैन वी डू
क्या हमें करना ही पड़ेगा मैं आपसे पूछ
जरूर हूं लेकिन करना मुझे खुद का ही होता
है मन का खुद का ही मैं करूंगा तो जब करना
है तो करना है वो मैं एक फॉर्मेलिटी के
लिए आपसे पूछ लेता हूं ठीक है तो आप बता
दीजिए फॉर्मेलिटी के लिए आप भी बता दीजिए
कि करें हां क्योंकि आप नहीं भी बोलेंगे
तो भी मैं
करूंगा ठीक
है बहुत
बढ़िया चलिए बहुत लोगों का बोला कि अ बहुत
लोगों ने बोला कि हां कर कर लेते हैं कर
लेते हैं तो तो करना ही है ठीक है तो चलिए
यहां पे एक वर्डप्रेस का वर्जन इंस्टॉल
करते हैं बट हम ओल्ड वर्जन इंस्टॉल करेंगे
ताकि हम वहां पे लेबिलिटी फाइंड करने की
कोशिश कर पाए पहले आपको मैं दिखा पाऊं कि
किस तरह से वनबिल फाइंड कर सकते हैं आप
सेम मेथड हम लाइव वेबसाइट पे भी अप्लाई
करेंगे आप लोगों का एक बहुत बड़ा
मिसकनसेप्शन क्या होता है ना पता है आप
लोगों के अंदर एक बहुत बहुत लोगों सबके
अंदर नहीं होता है बट बहुत लोगों के अंदर
एक मिसकनसेप्शन होती है कि सर आप ये
कभी-कभी जैसे डेमो वेबसाइट होती है या कुछ
होती है तो सर आप इस पे क्यों कर रहे हो
लाइव ट क्यों नहीं कर रहे हो यार लाइव पे
आओ ना लाइव वाली ही तो असली है बाकी तो
नकली है तो भाई जो तुम डेमो या जो तुम लैब
में कर रहे हो तुम सेम प्रोसेस ना बस एक
रियल मतलब तुम अगर डेमो वेबसाइट abc.com
है और रियल xyz.com है तो ए बीसी का में
सेम मेथड एक्वा z.com प अप्लाई करने का है
कुछ बदलना नहीं है भाई बस एक यूआरएल डोमेन
आईपी बदल देनी है खत्म कहानी राइट समझ में
आ गया
चलिए तो वर्डप्रेस को इंस्टॉल करने के लिए
भैया हम वर्डप्रेस का ओल्ड वर्जन एक
इंस्टॉल करने वाले हैं एंड इसके लिए पूरा
प्रोसेस देखिएगा समझिए थोड़ा मजा आएगा
आपको इसके लिए व्हाट वी नीड वी नीड अ
समथिंग क्या नीड हमें चाहिए इसके लिए हमें
चाहिए जम सर्वर एक एप जमप हमें चाहिए
वर्डप्रेस का ओल्ड वर्जन फाइल व ओल्ड
वर्जन जिप फाइल चाहिए हमें ये हमें चाहिए
ठीक है दो चीजें हमें चाहिए एंड हमें क्या
करना है हमें स्टार्ट
वेब सर्वर
एंड
एएल हेलो एसक्यूएल एंड वेब सर्वर ठीक
है चलिए आई थिंक मुझे मुझे लगा ऑडियो का
प्रॉब्लम है ठीक है ऑडियो तो बिल्कुल सही
है तो एसक्यूएल एंड वेब सर्वर जो है हमें
इसको स्टार्ट करना है तो जम के लिए ऑलरेडी
ऑलरेडी मुझे पता है आप सबने इंस्टॉल की
होगी पहले कि क्लासेस जिन्होंने देखी होगी
आप मुझे बताइए आप में से कितने लोगों के
जमप इंस्टॉल्ड है अभी तक बताइए मुझे जमप
विंडोस के अंदर
में बस तीन चार लोगों के बस पांच छह लोगों
के ओनली
चलिए चलिए कोई बात नहीं जमप अगर आपका
इंस्टॉल नहीं है तो मैं आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा आप सिंपल यहां पे जमप डाउनलोड कर
लीजिएगा या अरे मैं यह क्या कर रहा हूं
यार ब्राउजर में सर्च
कीजिएगा जस्ट अ सेकंड जम डाउनलोड यहां पे
जम का डाउनलोड का यह जो है ना इस वाले
सोर्स फोर्ज पे आप इस पर आ जाइएगा डाउनलोड
कर लीजिएगा मेरा जो यहां पे जमप है मैं
आपको दिखा देता ता हूं रन एज एडमिन करके
यहां पे यह मैं ओपन कर लेता हूं यहां पे
लेट्स
सी यहां पे मैं z का एक ओल्डर वर्जन यूज
कर रहा हूं इसका सबसे बड़ा रीजन है पीएचपी
का वर्जन पीएचपी वर्जन सेन मुझे चाहिए था
जो कि इस वर्जन में आपका परफेक्टली काम
करता है तो मैं 3.2.3 वर्जन यूज़ कर रहा
हूं जम का लेटेस्ट वर्जन में लेटेस्ट
वर्जन का पीएचपी आएगा जो कई सारे वेब
एप्लीकेशन के साथ प्रॉब्लम करता है
कॉन्फ्लेशन होती है तो मैं आपसे रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा कि एक पीएच ओल्ड वर्जन आप यूज
कीजिए तो ओल्ड वर्जन के लिए आप सिंपल यहां
पे आ
जाएंगे फाइल्स पे आएंगे फाइल्स पे जब
आएंगे तो आपको यहां पे जम फॉर
बनती है ठीक है उसके बाद आपको जम का जो
कंट्रोल पैनल है वोह एक्सेस करना होता है
ठीक है तो जब भी आप जम का कंट्रोल पैनल
एक्सेस करें एक रिक्वेस्ट है कि इसको आप
रन एज एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर की तरह एक्सेस करें
तो मैं इसको क्या कर देता हूं रन एज
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एक्सेस कर लेता हूं तो
यहां पे इस तरीके से ओपन हो जाता है चलिए
अब मैं यहां पे वर्डप्रेस का ओल्ड वर्जन
जो है वो डाउनलोड कर लेता हूं तो आप यहां
पे चलेंगे एंड ओल्ड वर्डप्रेस
डाउनलोड करके सर्च कर लेते हैं तो यहां पे
वपे ओज की रिलीज आर्काइव आएगी इसको क्लिक
करके ओपन कर लीजिएगा ठीक है ये रिलीज
आर्काइव है मैं इसको बैक कर देता हूं फ
forest.in वेबसाइट ओपन कर लेता हूं यह बंद
कर देता हूं ठीक है तो यहां पे वपस की
सारी वर्जंस आपको मिल जाएंगी अभी तक जितने
भी वर्जंस जो है लच हुए हैं वर्जन 0.71 से
1.1 सब कुछ करके तो यहां पे हम वर्जन 2.0
डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं सबसे ओल्ड वर्जन
थोड़ा वर्किंग वर्जन में आपको बोल सकता
हूं लाइक वर्किंग में गुड मान सकते हैं
इसको तो 2.0 क्योंकि इसमें अवेलेबिलिटीज
होंगी अच्छी खासी मुझे जहां तक लग रहा है
तो 2.0 मैंने यहां पे कर लिया है एंड इसका
सबसे पहला 2.0 ही 2.01 भी आप कर सकते हो
कोई सा भी कर लो कोई दिक्कत उसमें नहीं है
तो मैं यहां पे 2.0 का जिप फाइल जो है
डाउनलोड कर लेता हूं क्लिक करूंगा जिप पे
जिप फाइल डाउनलोड होना स्टार्ट हो जाएगी
एंड जिप फाइल जो है आपकी डाउनलोड हो जाएगी
इसको हम डाउनलोड फोल्डर में एक्सेस कर
लेते हैं इसको क्या करना है एक्सट्रैक्ट
कर देना है तो मैं यहां पे एक्सट्रैक्ट ऑल
कर देता हूं यहां पे एक्सट्रैक्ट कर देते
हैं ठीक है यहां एक्ट कर दिया हमने आ
जाएगी भाई बहुत सारी सीरीज आने वाली है
थोड़ा थोड़ा इंतजार कर लो और ये स्पैम
करोगे हाफिजा तो फिर मुझे आपको ब्लॉक करना
पड़ेगा स्पैम मत करो एक बार ही मैसेज करो
ठीक है तो यहां पे वपस 2.0 यहां पे आ चुका
है ठीक है एंड यहां पे वर्डप्रेस की एक
फोल्डर इसके अंदर आ चुकी है राइट यहां पे
वर्डप्रेस की क्या हो चुकी है फोल्डर आ
चुकी है अ सर एपीआई कीज को फाइंड करके
वेबसाइट को किस तरह से एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते
हैं उसके ऊपर एक वीडियो प्लीज ज्ञानेश
इसकी वीडियो यह जो एपीआई एक्सप्लोइटेशन की
बात आप कर रहे हो इसकी वीडियो भी आएगी बट
ये एडवांस पार्ट है या बोल सकते हैं एक
हायर इंटरमीडिएट लेवल पार्ट है तो ये जब
बेसिक टू इंटरमीडिएट कंप्लीट हो जाएगा
उसके बाद जो सीरीज आएंगी उसमें आएंगी ठीक
है तब तक आप खुद से या तो कर सकते हैं या
तो आपको वेट करना है तो वेट कर सकते हैं
तो यहां पे वपस नाम की एक फोल्डर आएगी अब
आपको क्या करना है जैंप आपने इंस्टॉल कर
लिया है सब कुछ कर लिया है नाउ व्हाट यू
हैव टू डू इस फोल्डर को कॉपी कर लेना है
कॉपी करने के बाद आपको सी ड्राइव में जमप
वाली फोल्डर में चलनी है और यहां पे एचटी
डॉक्स नाम का एक फोल्डर आपको मिलेगा देखो
एचटी डॉक्स कहां मिल रहा है ये रहा एचटी
डॉक्स एचटी डॉक्स में यहां पे जाना है एंड
यहां पे एचटी डॉक्स में जाके इसको पेस्ट
कर देना है पेस्ट कीजिएगा यहां कंटिन्यू
कर दीजिएगा एंड इट विल बी यहां पे
पेस्टेड जी हां जी हां जी हां
जो पैनल है कंट्रोल पैनल इसमें जाके अचे
और माय एएल को स्टार्ट करना है तो मैं
यहां पे अचे को स्टार्ट करता हूं लेट्स सी
स्टार्ट हो चुकी है मैं यहां पे माए
स्टार्ट करता हूं लेट्स सी स्टार्ट हो
चुकी है अब यहां पे अचे मेरा तो इजली
स्टार्ट हो चुका है पोर्ट 8443 पे एंड मा
sql3 30306 पोर्ट पे तो मा स्कल स्टार्ट
करने में मुझे नहीं लगता किसी को इश्यूज
आएंगे बट अचे को स्टार्ट जब आप करोगे
कभी-कभी प्रॉब्लम आ जाती है पोर्ट
डिपेंडेंसीज की पोर्ट ब्लॉक ब्लॉक्ड पोर्ट
की वजह से कि इसका मतलब यह होता है कि
आपका पोर्ट नंबर 80 या 443 ऑलरेडी कोई और
और सर्विस जो है यूज कर रहा है तो यह
स्टार्ट नहीं हो पाएगा उस केस में आपको
यहां पे इसके कॉन्फिन में अचे की जो
कॉन्फिन फाइल होती है उसमें जाके एंड वहां
पे पोर्ट चेंज करना पड़ता है ये मैंने
पहले की वीडियोस में बता रखे हैं तो आप
वहां से भी देख सकते हैं ठीक है क्योंकि
हम ज्यादा उसमें टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे
तो हमारी जो है ये अचे एंड सर्वर एक तरह
से स्टार्ट हो चुकी है अब इसको हम चेक
कैसे करेंगे तो ये सर्वर जो स्टार्ट होती
है लोकल होस्ट पे होती है तो लोकल होस्ट
करके एंटर करेंगे तो आपको यहां पे ये पेज
देखने को मिल जाएगा जम अचे प्लस मारया
डीबी प्लस पीएचपी प् पर्ल यानी कि यू हैव
सक्सेसफुली स्टार्टेड योर सर्वर अब भैया
क्या करना है अब आती है मेन चीज मेन चीज
क्या है वर्डप्रेस को इंस्टॉल करना है
हमारी जो वल्नरेबल वर्डप्रेस है ओल्ड
वर्जन का उसको इंस्टॉल करना है आपके लोकल
होस्ट पे ठीक
है चलिए अब यहां पे वर्डप्रेस को इंस्टॉल
करने के लिए हमें उस पाथ को एक्सेस करने
पड़ेगा जहां पे वर्डप्रेस है तो वपस कहां
पे है जम के अंदर में एचटी डॉक्स में देखो
यहां पे एचटी डॉक्स के अंदर ये रहा
वर्डप्रेस वाली
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री एक्सेस करने के लिए
डैशबोर्ड के जगह पे यहां पे करेंगे
वर्डप्रेस और हम यहां एंटर करेंगे जैसे ही
हम एंटर करेंगे अब यहां पे आ रहा है देयर
डज नॉट सीम टू बी अ wpc.gov.in
तो तुम अब मुझे बताओ कि इसको फाइल यह
चाहिए तो हम देखते हैं डब्ल्यूपी कॉन्फिन
यहां पे तो वर्डप्रेस के अंदर चलते हैं
एंड यहां
पे यह रहा डब्ल्यूपी कॉन्ग सैंपल अच्छा ये
डब्ल्यूपी कॉफ h सल पीए ये फाइल अवेलेबल
है ठीक हैड इसको रिनेम कर दिया मतलब सपल
पीएपी कर दिया गया है इसलिए ये फाइल
अवेलेबल है तो अब देखो यहां पे ना एक चीज
है यहां पे अब एक एक प्रॉब्लम क्या है मैं
यहां पे क्या कर देता हूं राइट क्लिक करता
हूं इसको रिनेम कर देता हूं यहां पे मैं
सिंपल क्या कर देता हूं सैंपल को हटा देता
हूं क्योंकि इसको चाहिए w
कफिल कफ पीएपी कर देता हूं एंड नाउ लेट्स
रीलोड दिस पेज नाउ लेट्स
रीलोड अब हमने रीलोड किया तो यहां आ रहा
है एरर एस्टेब्लिशिंग अ डेटाबेस कनेक्शन
दिस आइर मींस द यूजर नेम पासवर्ड
इंफॉर्मेशन इन योर wpc.gov.in
क् आ रही है मुझे कोई बताएगा कि एरर डेटा
बेस कनेक्शन में क्यों एरर आ रहा है मुझे
बताइए एनी
वन मुझे प्रोफेशनल बग हंटर बनना है कितना
टाइम लगेगा टाइम लग जाएगा एक
साल बताइए मुझे कोई बताइए लेट मी नो गाइस
एनीबडी
एनीबडी कनेक्शन नहीं है तो ऐड करो सर्वर
ऑफ है सर्वर चल रहा है भाई यूजर नेम
पासवर्ड न डेटाबेस सेम नहीं है मायल डे
नॉट कनेक्टेड हां यह तो आ ही रहा
है ठीक है तो यहां पर यह प्रॉब्लम आ रही
है तो हम डप कफ पीएपी को ओपन करके एक बार
देख लेते हैं कि आखिर प्रॉब्लम है क्या तो
मैं नोटपैड प्लस प्लस एडिट कर लेता हूं
यहां पर अब देखो यहां प ना यहां देखो मैं
एक चीज दिखाता हूं w कग पीएपी जो यहां पे
ये फाइल बेसिकली आपकी है ना यह फाइल इस
फाइल में एक डेटाबेस नेम है वर्डप्रेस
डेटाबेस का नाम क्या दिया हुआ है
वर्डप्रेस दिया हुआ है बट हमारे पास क्या
यह डेटाबेस अवेलेबल है बट क्या हमारे पास
यह डेटाबेस अवेलेबल है हमारे पास यह
डेटाबेस बना हुआ है वर्डप्रेस नाम का चलिए
इसको भी हम देख लेते हैं तो इसके लिए हम
क्या करेंगे हमें जाना है यहां पे मा स्
वाले पे एंड यहां पे एडमिन करके एक ऑप्शन
है पीएचपी माय एडमिन का आपके एंप में इस
पे क्लिक कर देना है तो यह आपका पीएचपी
माय एडमिन ओपन करेगा चलिए वेट करते हैं तो
ये आप देख रहे हो पीएचपी माय एडमिन
स्टार्ट ओपन हो चुका है जहां पे हम डेटा
बेसस को मैनेज करते हैं तो यहां पे आप
डेटा बेसेस के लिस्ट में देखेंगे तो यहां
पे कहीं पे भी वर्डप्रेस नाम की डेटाबेस
नहीं है भाई नो वर्डप्रेस डेटाबेस या कुछ
नहीं है ठीक है समझ में आ गया इसका मतलब
क्या है हमारे पास डेटाबेस ही नहीं है यार
फिर कैसे काम चलेगा डेटाबेस तो बना ही
नहीं है वर्डप्रेस नाम का कोई फिर कैसे
काम चलेगा तो हम क्या करते हैं wpc.gov.in
न्यू पे क्लिक
करेंगे डेटाबेस नाम हम वर्डप्रेस
देंगे डेटाबेस नाम हम क्या देंगे
वर्डप्रेस देंगे वर्डप्रेस क्योंकि सेम
नेम आप दे दीजिएगा वर्डप्रेस यहां पे
क्रिएट जो भी नाम देना है दे सकते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है लेकिन मैं वर्डप्रेस ही दे
रहा हूं ठीक है एंड यहां पे मैं क्रिएट कर
रहा हूं चलिए क्रिएट किया हमने वर्डप्रेस
नाम की डेटाबेस यहां पे क्रिएट हो चुकी है
बहुत बढ़िया अब इसको हम क्लोज कर देते हैं
ठीक है भाई डन अब हम क्या करते हैं इसको
रीलोड करते हैं अगेन यहां पे ना हियर एक
बार क्या करते हैं जम को स्टॉप करके
स्टार्ट करते हैं स्टॉप कर देते हैं दोनों
अचे माल दोनों ही स्टार्ट एंड फिर से
स्टार्ट कर देते हैं हमारी सर्वर को मा
एएल को हमने चेंज किया है तो हम यहां पे
स्टार्ट कर देते हैं चलिए अब हम क्या कर
देते हैं अगेन हम यहां पे वर्डप्रेस पे
चलते हैं एंटर करते हैं यहां पे अगेन यहां
पे क्रिएट डब्ल्यूपी कॉन्फिडो अ वेब
इंटरफेस आ रहा है यहां पे चलते हैं अब
यहां पे जब चलेंगे तो आ रहा है कि ये
वेलकम टू वर्डप्रेस बिफोर गेटिंग
स्टार्टेड ये कुछ डिटेल्स चाहिए चलिए
लेट्स गो पे क्लिक करते हैं अब यहां पे
लेट्स गो पे क्लिक करने यहां पे आ रहा है
डेटाबेस नेम तो हमने डेटाबेस नेम
वर्डप्रेस नाम से बनाया था तो वर्डप्रेस
यहां देना है जिस नाम से बनाइए वही नाम
यहां देना है यूजर नेम में आप कुछ भी डाल
सकते हैं आपकी मर्जी है मैं एडमिन डाल
देता हूं पासवर्ड आप ब्लैंक कर दीजिए
पासवर्ड बाद में आप खुद से यह जनरेट करके
भी दे देगा या तो आप खुद से सेट कर लीजिए
आपकी मर्जी है अभी फिलहाल में ब्लैंक छोड़
देता हूं ठीक है एंड यहां पे मैं सबमिट
करता हूं सबमिट करेंगे यह देखिए यहां पे
क्या आ रहा है कैन सेलेक्ट डेटाबेस वी आर
वी आर वी वेर एबल टू कनेक्ट टू डेटाबेस
सर्वर ठीक है यहां पे क्या आ रहा है यहां
पे वच मींस य यूजर पासवर्ड इज ओके बट नॉट
एबल टू सेलेक्ट द वर्डप्रेस डेटाबेस नॉट
एबल टू सेलेक्ट द वर्डप्रेस डेटाबेस आर यू
श्यर इट एजिस्ट ऑन सम सिस्टम द नेम ऑफ योर
डेटाबेस प्रीफिक्स्ड विद योर यूज़र नेम सो
इट वुड बी लाइक यूज़र नेम वर्डप्रेस कैंड
वुड बी प्रॉब्लम तो यह प्रॉब्लम एक आ रही
है भैया अब यह आ रही है प्रॉब्लम तो अब
इसका क्या सॉल्यूशन है अब यह भी देख लेते
हैं मैं बैक करता हूं यहां पे अब यहां पे
मैं ना यहां पे यूज़र नेम मान लो रूट दे
देते हैं चलो रूट दे देते हैं अब यहां पे
सबमिट करते हैं तो यहां पे जैसे ही हमने
रूट दिया हमारा काम यहां पर हो गया तो
यहां पर यूजर नेम जो है यहां पर हमने चेंज
करना था बेसिकली व्हाट वी हैव टू डू वी
हैव टू गिव इट डिफरेंट यूजर नेम रूट अब
यहां पर हम रन द इंस्टॉल कर ले रन द
इंस्टॉल तो यहां प हमें करना है रन द
इंस्टॉल यहां पर क्लिक करेंगे यहां आ रहा
है वेलकम टू वर्डप्रेस इंस्टॉलेशन वी आर
नाउ गोइंग टू इंस्टॉल तो फर्स्ट स्टेप प
क्लिक करना है यहां वेबसाइट का टाइटल दे
देना है तो मैं कर देता हूं
डेनिक्स वर्डप्रेस हंटिंग
ईमेल डाल देते हैं तो मैं ईमेल डाल देता
हूं नक् @gmail क मैंने यहां पे ईमेल डाल
दिया ठीक है एंड यहां पे मैं कर देता हूं
कंटिन्यू टू सेकंड स्टेप्स कंटिन्यू टू
सेकंड स्टेप करते हैं यहां पे एंड डन खत्म
आ चुका हमारा यहां पे अब यहां पे मैं इसकी
ना यहां पे इसको मैं स्क्रीनशॉट लेके या
जो भी है यूजर नेम पासवर्ड मैं जो है इसको
यहां पे कॉपी कर लेता हूं तो मैं यहां पे
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड जो है इसका कॉपी कर लेता
हूं एंड यहां पे मैं क्या लिख रहा है यूजर
नेम एडमिन है आपका और पासवर्ड आपका यह है
यानी कि पासवर्ड ये एंड यूजर नेम एडमिन से
आपको लॉगइन कर लेनी है ठीक है यूजर नेम यह
और पासवर्ड यह से लॉगइन कर लेनी है तो
चलिए अब यहां पे चलते हैं लॉगिन पे क्लिक
करते हैं लॉगिन पे क्लिक करेंगे यूजर नेम
यहां डालेंगे एडमिन पासवर्ड डालेंगे सेम
जैसे हमें बताया गया वहां एंड लॉगइन पे
क्लिक करेंगे लॉगइन पे क्लिक करते ही दिस
विल बी लॉग इन वर्डप्रेस में आप लॉगइन हो
चुके हैं गाइस डैशबोर्ड के अंदर आप यहां
देख सकते हैं डैशबोर्ड राइट मैनेज लिंक
यूजर्स सब कुछ आ रहा है यहां पे ठीक है अब
आप पूछेंगे वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट कौन सी है
भाई तो यह वर्डप्रेस पे है ना यह रही
वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट आपकी जो हमने अभी तुरंत
किया था सो वी हैव द वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट र
सो वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट मिल चुकी है भैया
हमारे पास लग लॉग आउट करना है लॉग आउट कर
दीजिए यहां से आप लॉग आउट हो चुके हैं
यहां से एंड यहां से आप वर्डप्रेस को
वेबसाइट को विजिट कर रहे हैं सो वी हैव
सेट अप अ वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट वर्जन 2.0 ऑन
दिस पर्टिकुलर एड्रेस लोकल होस्ट स् 120
वपस वपे पे ठीक है ये हमने कर लिया
ठीक है गॉट इट अब यहां पे जब आप सी ड्राइव
में जब यहां जम में जब यहां एटी डॉक्स में
वर्डप्रेस के अंदर जब आप यहां आएंगे तो
यहां आप देखेंगे कि एक डब्ल्यूपी कॉग ड
पीप फाइल बनी है डप कफ पीप फाइल बन गई है
पहले एक सैंपल वाली थी बट यहां हमने एक और
क्रिएट कर दी है जब हमने खुद से मैनुअली
किया जब आप इसको एडिट विथ नोटपैड प्लस
प्लस करेंगे तो आपको यहां पर देखने को
मिलेगा कि व डेटाबेस नेम है यूजर नेम रूट
है आपका यहां पे एंड यहां पासवर्ड आपका
ब्लैंक करके रखा हुआ है लोकल होस्ट पे समझ
में आ गया तो यह आपको यहां पे देखने को
मिल जाएगा अब बात यहां पे है कि क्या हम
इसको ऐसे एक्सेस कर सकते हैं
12701 वर्डप्रेस इस तरीके से तो आप लॉगइन
इस तरीके से भी आप इसको एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं 12700 ठीक है ल फ्रॉम इंडिया ब्रदर तो
हमारा वर्डप्रेस सेटअप हो चुका है तो चलिए
अब क्या करना है हमें अब हमें इस
वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट पे डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ
टेस्टिंग पहले करनी है एंड देन हम आगे की
तरफ भैया बढ़ेंगे व पलाइज को जरूर इंस्टॉल
कर लीजिएगा यह काफी ज्यादा आपके लिए
यूज़फुल होगा ठीक है जो हो बहुत ज्यादा
बहुत ज्यादा चलिए तो अब गाइस हम क्या करने
वाले हैं व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू
डू वी आर गोइंग टू यूज अ द टूल एक टूल हम
यूज करना जा रहे हैं प्रॉब्लम क्या आ रहा
है योर पीएचपी इंस्टॉलेशन अपीयर्स टू बी
मिसिंग द माल विच इज ड फॉरवर्ड माल को
स्टार्ट कर लीजिए आप अपने सी पैनल से यहां
पर कंट्रोल पैनल से जैम के मायकल जो है
स्टार्ट होना चाहिए यह देखिए पी आईडी
प्रोसेस आईडी आपको एक मिली होगी पोर्ट कौन
सा है 3306 प मा स्कल स्टार्ट होगा तभी
आपका काम करेगा अचे स्टार्ट होगा तभी आपका
काम करेगा ठीक है
भैया
निर्ग मा स् स्टार्ट है फिर क्या प्रॉब्लम
है फिर कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं होनी चाहिए माल
फिर कुछ आपकी प्रॉब्लम होगी अगर आपका मा
स्कल रन कर रहा है तो ट्रबल शूट कर सकते
हो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है मुझे पता है
तुम्हारे लिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है दूसरा
कोई होता तो फिर ज्यादा दिक्कत होती तुम
कर लोगे आराम से कर लो ठीक है क्योंकि
मुझे समझ नहीं आएगा जब तक मैं देखूं
ना सर मेरे नहीं चल रहा कैसे नहीं चल रहा
चलना चाहिए भाई चलना चाहिए यही तो ट्रबल
शूटिंग है यही तो प्रॉब्लम सॉल्विंग है
कैसे नहीं चलेगा मेरा कैसे चल रहा है आप
बताइए ना आप खुद बताइए आपके सामने किया
मैंने पूरा पूरा प्रोसेस आई डिड इन फ्रंट
ऑफ यू है
ना लप कफ पीएपी कर दिया करना क्यों है खुद
से एक और फाइल बन जाएगी भाई जब मैनुअली
क्रिएट करोगे एसटी डॉक्स के अंदर में
वर्डप्रेस के अंदर में तो भैया खुद से एक
और फाइल डब्ल्यूपी कॉन्फिन भी रहेगी ड कफ
पीएपी बन जाएगी जो आपने क्रिएट किया रहेगा
इट वर्क्स वेरी गुड हां जी कॉपी मत करो
यार बिल्कुल सही बोला जस्ट डोंट कॉपी गाइस
आपको ना थोड़ा यार खुद से करो ना खुद के
लिए खुद से समझो अब पूरा का पूरा मैं जो
कर रहा हूं वही कॉपी करोगे तो फिर कैसे
काम चलेगा थोड़ा कांसेप्ट को समझ लोगे तो
कहीं भी इंस्टॉल कर लोगे है ना तो प्लीज
डोंट डू दैट थिंग राइट
गाइस चलिए तो अब हम जो है इसके लिए एक टूल
का यूज करने वाले हैं दैट टूल इज नोन एज
डब्लू पी स्कैन काफी बढ़िया और शानदार टूल
है इसके लिए हम काली लिनिक्स को स्टार्ट
कर लेते हैं पहले तो लेट्स स्टार्ट काली
लिनिक्स काली में करने वाले हैं मैं इसको
स्टार्ट कर रहा
हूं
प्लीज अगर इनको वर्डप्रेस लोकल होस्ट पर
चलाना नहीं आता हैकिंग क्या करेंगे ऐसा
नहीं है गा ऐसा नहीं है यार किसी किसी को
होती है प्रॉब्लम जा कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है
कभी-कभी प्रॉब्लम्स आ जाती है ब धीरे-धीरे
सीख जाएंगे धीरे-धीरे सीखेंगे ठीक है आई
नो बहुत बेसिक चीज है ये बट स्टिल टाइम
लगता है कभी-कभी बहुत लोगों को है ना
तो सभी लोग क्या होते हैं स्टार्टिंग में
तो नब भी होते हैं किसी को कुछ नहीं पता
होता तो धीरे-धीरे धीरे धीरे सीखेंगे
सीखेंगे तभी तो आगे एक्सपर्ट
बनेंगे यस यस यू कैन वच
ज्ञानेश मैंने भी आपसे सीखा है धन्यवाद
इको
माइल
चलिए यहां पे मैं डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन को
इंस्टॉल करने की कोशिश करता हूं
लेट्स सी बट आई थिंक डब्ल्यूपी स्कन
ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल होगा तो
एट एट लिस्ट डब्ल्यूपी स्कन ऑलरेडी है ना
है तो यह इंस्टॉल्ड है ऑलरेडी तो
एट यहां पे यह टूल यूज है डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन
ठीक है एंड हान एस दे देते हैं इसकी हेल्प
फाइल के लिए तो आपको डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन की
पूरी हेल्प फाइल जो है यहां पे दिख जाएगी
ठीक है किस तरीके से आपको डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन
यूज करना है कैसे चलाना है सब कुछ आपको
दिख जाएगा यहां पर मैं इसका प काली का
ब्राउजर ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड यहां पर हम
हम अपनी वेबसाइट को एक्सेस करने की देखते
हैं
127 ओके यहां पर शायद यह नहीं होगी यहां
पर हमारी होगी
192.168
2943 एंड यह इस पर हम एक्सेस कर
पाएंगे यहां पर हम वर्डप्रेस प चलते हैं
वर्डप्रेस जो हम एक्सेस कर रहे हैं तो यह
हमारी वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट जो है यह हमारी आ
चुकी है ठीक है यह थोड़ा अजीब सा हो रहा
है बट ठीक है काम चल जाएगा हमारी वेबसाइट
यहां पे ओपन हो रही है एक्सेस कर पा रहे
हैं दैट्ची है चलिए तो डब्ल्यूपी स्कन जो
है यह क्या है मैं आपको बता देता हूं एक
वर्डप्रेस सिक्योरिटी स्कैनर है बाय
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन टीम ठीक है एंड यहां पे
इसके बहुत ही शानदार यूज केसेस हैं
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन करके आप वपस की बहुत सारी
वलने एबिलिटीज बहुत बहुत तरीके से ढूंढ
सकते हैं देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स दैट यू
कैन डू विद डब्ल्यूपी स्कन करना क्या है
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन हाईफा फन यूआरएल देना है
एंड आपको जो यूआरएल चाहिए वो यूआरएल दे
देना है एंड उसके बाद आप अलग-अलग ऑप्शंस
यूज कर सकते हैं सबसे पहले यहां पे आप
देखते हैं यहां पे तो मैं यहां पे अ
दिखाता हूं आपको थ्रेडिंग - t लगा के आप
थ्रेड की वैल्यू बढ़ा सकते हैं मैक्सिमम
जो है डिफॉल्ट फाइव है इसको आप 10 15 20
कर सकते हैं आपकी मर्जी है फास्ट थोड़ी
थ्रेडिंग बढ़ा देने के लिए उसके बाद नीचे
की तरफ आप आएंगे तो यहां पे जो है ना
एन्यूमरेशन प्रोसेस है तो ये नमरे करेगा
तो इनमेट क्या करेगा यहां पे देखो
एन्यूमरेशन जब न e लगा आप तो यहां पर एी
लगाओगे ऑल प्लगइन के लिए वीपी लगाओगे
वल्नरेबल प्लगइन के लिए पहली बात तो हमें
यार ऑल प्लगइन से क्या मतलब है हमें चाहिए
जो वल्नरेबल प्लगइन है वो लेकर आ ना वो
बताओ मुझे है ना यह चाहिए हमें फिर पॉपुलर
प्लगइन यहां प वटी वल्नरेबल थीम्स के लिए
ऑल थीम्स के लिए ए लगाओगे पॉपुलर थीम्स के
लिए सारी चीज है ठीक है यू कैन पुट इट ऑन
उसके बाद नीचे आओ यहां
पे नीचे आओ यहां पर और भी ऑप्श यहां पर
मिलेंगे आपको यहां पर अ ये आ रहा है यहां
पे लाइक प्लगइन डिटेक्शन मोड ठीक है तो
यूज द सप्लाइड मोड टू इनमेट प्लगिंस
डिफॉल्ट पैसिव है यहां पे तो यहां पे प्लग
इन डिटेक्शन मोड जो है इनेबल आप कर सकते
हो उसी तरीके से प्लगइन वर्जन का डिटेक्शन
आप इनेबल कर सकते हो ये सारी चीजें आप कर
सकते हो इसमें अलग-अलग ऑप्शंस है तो चलिए
हम एक काम करते हैं यहां पे डब्ल्यूपी
स्कैन अ चलिए डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन कर लेते
हैं एंड यहां पे हाइफान हाइफान यूआरएल दे
देते हैं एंड यूआरएल हमारा ये वाला दे
देते हैं जो हमारा लोकल होस्ट पे चल रहा
है यह हम यूआरएल प्रोवाइड कर देते हैं
लेट्स प्रोवाइड द यूआरएल तो यह यूआरएल
आपकी बन चुकी है आ चुकी है वर्डप्रेस पे
उसके बाद हम यहां पे इनमेट करने की कोशिश
करते हैं तो हान e लगाएंगे एंड हाइन e के
बाद यहां पे हम क्या लगाएंगे गाइस क्या
इनमेट करना है तो हमें वल्नरेबल थीम्स एंड
वल्नरेबल प्लगिंस इनमेट करनी है ठीक है
भैया वल्नरेबल थीम्स एंड वल्नरेबल प्लगिंस
हमें तो पहले हमें वल्नरेबल मान लो
कि लेट्स सी वल्नरेबल पहले प्लगइन ही कर
लेते हैं है ना पहले हम प्लगिंस वल्नरेबल
प्लगिंस ही ढूंढ लेते हैं तो न वप
वल्नरेबल प्लगिंस यह हम करते हैं और एंटर
करते हैं एंटर करेंगे तो यहां पे आ रहा
है ओके ओके ओके सॉरी सॉरी
सॉरी तो यहां पे हम वीपी कर देते हैं हान
वीपी वेबल प्लगिंस के लिए तो अब यहां पे
देख सकते हैं अपडेटिंग द डेटा बेस एंड
यहां पे आपको जो स्कैनिंग है वो स्टार्ट
हो चुकी है एंड स्कैनिंग स्टार्ट हो चुकी
है स्कैनिंग स्टार्ट होते ही यहां पे आपके
पास रिजल्ट आ चुका है ठीक है अब रिजल्ट जब
आएगा यहां पे तो आप यूआरएल देख सकते हैं
यहां पे स्टार्टेड यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं कि हेडर्स यहां पे इंटरेस्टिंग
एंट्रीज यहां पे आ रही है यहां पे यहां पे
कुछ अ जो अ हेडर्स के इंटरेस्टिंग है वो
इंटरेस्टिंग हेडर्स आपको दिखा रहे हैं
भैया उसके बाद डमी फाउंड यहां पे मिला है
यहां पे डायरेक्ट एक्स एक्सेस यहां पे
उसके बाद वर्डप्रेस वर्जन 2.0
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
कोई भी प्लगइन यहां पे नहीं है चलिए बहुत
बढ़िया बात है अब हम यहां पे कर देते हैं
वल्नरेबल थीम्स वटी इसको अब एक बार चेक
आउट करते हैं लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग
चलिए तो ये वल्नरेबल थीम्स फाइंड करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है तो यहां पे जो है आपको
मिल रहा है कि नो थीम्स फाउंड यानी कि कोई
भी थीम यहां पे प्रेजेंट बेसिकली नहीं है
कोई भी वल्नरेबल थीम्स क्या थीम्स ही नहीं
है तो यहां पे कुछ नहीं दिखा रहा जैसे ही
अगर थीम्स या प्लगिंस जो है वो अगर यहां
मिल जाता है कोई भी वल्नरेबल तो आपको यह
दिखा देगा ठीक
है क्या
बोले अ बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बहुत बहुत
सही ठीक है तो यहां पे अभी दिख रहा है
आपको कमांड मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं कमांड
आपको दिखा अभी जो कमांड हमने यूज किया
सिंपल सायह कमांड यूज किया हमने डब्ल्यूपी
स्कैन इस तरीके से ये ये कमांड हमने यूज
किया वटी एंड यहां पे तो यहां पे हमें
हमारे पास कोई भी इस तरह का वो नहीं है
प्लगइन व तो इसलिए इस तरीके से आ रहा है
अब मान लो मुझे यहां पे लॉगइन करना है
मुझे व्हाट वी हैव टू डू वी हैव टू लॉगइन
तो मैं लॉगइन करता हूं यहां पे एंड एडमिन
यूजर डाल देता हूं पासवर्ड हमारा क्या था
भाई पासवर्ड एक मैनुअल पासवर्ड था शायद तो
यह रही
पासवर्ड इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं ये पासवर्ड
तुम देख भी लोगे तो कुछ फर्क नहीं पड़ेगा
लोकल होस्ट पे है भाई
साहब यहां पे आ गए अब यहां प्लगिंस पे आते
हैं प्लगिंस प देखोगे यहां पे तो यहां पे
कुछ भी प्लगिंस में यहां पे नहीं आ रहा
यहां पे तीन प्लगिंस दिख रहे हैं यहां पे
वर्डप्रेस डेटाबेस बैकअप यहां पे आ रहा है
यहां पे हेलो डॉली आ रहा है एक्समेट आ रहा
है यहां तीन प्लगिंस आ रहे हैं ठीक है तो
मैं क्या कर देता हूं यहां पे एक प्लगइन
को एक्टिवेट कर देता हूं कोई भी प्लगइन
एक्टिवेट नहीं है यहां पे बेसिकली तो मैं
यहां पे क्या कर देता हूं एक प्लगइन को
एक्टिवेट कर देता हूं चलिए प्लगइन
एक्टिवेटेड हो क्या एक और प्लगइन है इसको
भी एक्टिवेट कर देते हैं दूसरा भी
एक्टिवेट हो गया प्लग इन है तीसरा भी
एक्टिवेट हो जाते हैं ठीक है तो यहां पे
हमने यहां पे सबको एक्टिवेट कर दिया अब हम
यहां पे चल जाते हैं अ ऑप्शंस पे एंड
लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज अ थीम थीम तो एक खैर
हमारी डिफॉल्ट वाली डली होगी बट बट यूजर्स
पे चल देते हैं यूजर्स हमारे ये हैं अ
प्रेजेंटेशन ठीक है ये थीम है करंट जो
करंट थीम है 1 प डिफॉल्ट 1.5 ये वाली थीम
डली हुई है थीम आप चाहे तो आप थीम भी यहां
पे चेंज कर सकते हैं या इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं वो आपकी मर्जी है तो जो भी थीम है
करंट यहां पे आपकी ये थीम है तो हमने यहां
पे प्लग इन एक अपडेट प्लग इन क्या किया है
भैया हमने यहां पे एक एक्टिवेट किया है तो
अब हम क्या कर देते हैं नाना एक अगेन सेम
कमांड डालते हैं वल्नरेबल प्लगिंस वाली
चेक आउट करते हैं कि हमारे पास कोई प्लगइन
इसमें अब डिटेक्ट करता है कि नहीं करता है
क्योंकि हमने प्लगइन को एक्टिवेट किया है
सो लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग अ नहीं ये डिटेक्ट नहीं कर रहा है
यहां पे ओबवियसली कोई डिटेक्शन नहीं है
कोई वो नहीं है तो अब जो है ना इस वाली
पर्टिकुलर चीज के अंदर में आपको कोई भी जो
वर्डप्रेस की आपकी जो टारगेट है या जो कि
आपका होस्ट है जिसको कि आप इनमेट करना
चाहते हैं प्लगिंस को या जिस पे आप हंट
करना चाहते हैं वो आप लगा सकते हैं अब
मुझे यहां पे यहां
पे इनमेट ऑल प्लगिंस पर कर चलते हैं ए ऑल
प्लग देखते हैं इ फाइंडिंग
समथिंग नहीं यह फाइंड नहीं कर पा रहा कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है अब हम एक काम करते हैं
यहां पे सेम जो चीज है यहां पर हमने जो इस
चीज के लिए किया तो अब हम एक लाइव वेबसाइट
पर ट्राई करते हैं लाइव वेबसाइट कौन सी है
भैया हमारे पास हमारे पास लाइव वेबसाइट है
फूट forest.in ठीक है
क्या
हुआ क्या हुआ भाई क्या हुआ देखो यहां पे
गाइस प्लीज प्लीज सी यर प्लीज इधर फोकस कर
लो यार इधर ध्यान दो ठीक है इधर ध्यान दो
ठीक है अब हम यहां पे एक लाइव वेबसाइट ले
रहे हैं यहां पे लाइव वेबसाइट में हम सेम
कमांड डालते देखो आप लोग बोलते हो ना लाइफ
पे नहीं करते क्यों करते हो लैब्स पे
क्यों करते हो एक् एक्से कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है भाई कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कहीं से भी
कर लो कोई सब सेम ही होता है अब मैं यहां
पर जो डाला है मैंने यूआरएल मैं यहां पर
चेंज कर दूंगा बस सिंपल मैं यहां प एक
लाइव वेबसाइट का यूआरएल दे देता हूं ए
यहां पर हमने लाइव वेबसाइट प यूआरएल दे
दिया एंड यहां पे एक
सेकंड यहां पर एक चीज देखना है
मुझे न तो य अब मैं एक लाइव वेबसाइट देते
हैं यहां पर ऑल प्लग
इनस ऑल प्लग प चलते हैं य प ल प्लग प करके
यहां प एंड यहां प एंटर करते हैं लेट्स सी
व्ट इ
हैपनिंग फूट फस्ट यहां पर हम एक लाइव
वेबसाइट का एग्जांपल ले रहे हैं फफ जो
हमें मिला था ग डक के थ्रू उसको हम यूज कर
रहे
हैं सो दिस इ दिस वन इट्स नमिंग गाइस यह
नरेट कर रहा है देखते जाओ
तुम लोग बोलते हो ना लाइव वेबसाइट लाइव
वेबसाइट इस तरीके से ठीक
है यह
देखो यह तुम्हें यहां पे यह तुम्हें यहां
पे रिजल्ट मिल गया टोटल रिजल्ट जो भी
रिजल्ट है यहां पे मिल गया अब यहां पे इस
रिजल्ट में जब तुम देखोगे तो यू विल सी अ
लॉट ऑफ इंफोज बहुत सारी इंफोज देखोगे देखो
क्या है फूट फड आ है यहां पे इंटरेस्टिंग
फाइंडिंग एक हेडर आई है यहां पे स अचे
2.4.5 ठीक है भैया पैसिव डिटेक्शन के थ्रू
हुआ है यह robots.txt फाइंड हुई है ये
अच्छी बात है robot.txt को ओपन करके देख
लेना अच्छी बात है कि कौन सी चीज अलाउड है
नहीं अलाउड है तो डिस अलाउ डब्ल्यूपी
एडमिन है बाकी कुछ खास यहां पे है नहीं तो
कोई बात नहीं एक्सएमएल आरपीसी सीम्स टू बी
इनेबल्ड ये एक इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है कि
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी इनेबल्ड है अब इसको ना हम
एग्जीक्यूट एक्सप्लोइट करके देखेंगे
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी को भैया हम एक्सप्लोइट
करके देखेंगे कि भैया आखिर एक्सएमएल
आरपीसी से क्या करेंगे आखिर व्हाट वी विल
डू फ्रॉम एक्सएमएल आरपीसी से क्या कर सकते
हैं किस तरीके से आप इसकी लेबिलिटी को
रिपोर्ट आउट कर सकते हैं या डॉस अटैक के
लिए कई बार यूज किया जाता है ठीक है भैया
ठीक है तो xmlrpc.php इधर देख लो यार सभी
लोग इधर देख लो इधर ध्यान दे लो चैट में
तुम लोग यार लड़ाई करने लगते हो यार समझ
नहीं आता मुझे तो तुम लोग चैट में क्यों
इधर चले जाते हो इतना चैट में अपना टाइम
वेस्ट मत किया करो यार अपना ठीक है तो
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी इनेबल्ड होना चाहिए तो
भैया ठीक है यहां पे देखो डायरेक्ट एक्सेस
से यहां पे फाइंड किया 100% कॉन्फिडेंस के
साथ बोल रहा है कि भैया इनेबल्ड है अब
यहां पे रेफरेंसेस में आपको यहां पे दे
रहा है कि एक्सएमएल आरपीसी के बारे में
यहां पे देख लीजिए भैया कि यहां पे इसके
मॉड्यूस भी अवेलेबल है मेटा एक्सप्लोइट के
उसपे को भी उसको भी आप चला के देख सकते
हैं xmlrpc.php
[संगीत]
के एरर्स लॉग होते हैं या अलग-अलग तरह के
जो भी अ चीजें आपकी अपडेट होती है यहां पे
आपको सब कुछ दिख जाएगा बेसिकली तो आपको
यहां पे डीबगिंग के जितने लॉग्स हैं व
सारे यहां पे देखने को मिलेंगे कई बार इन
लॉग्स के अंदर कई सारी इंफॉर्मेशन जो है
वो आपको मिलती है ठीक है जो यूज़फुल आपके
लिए हो सकती है तो ये आपको मिल गया
रजिस्ट्रेशन इज इनेबल्ड तो रजिस्ट्रेशन
इनेबल्ड है तो आप रजिस्टर करके एक बार
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं कहीं कुछ हो जाए अ
ठीक है उसके बाद एक्सटर्नल डब्ल्यूपी
क्रॉन सीम्स टू बी इनेबल्ड क्रॉन सर्विसेस
एक्सटर्नल जो है वो इनेबल्ड है बट
कॉन्फिडेंस 60 पर है नॉट 100% एंड यहां पे
जो है जो है वर्डप्रेस वर्जन जो है वो
पाया गया है जो कि इनसिक्योर है भैया
वर्डप्रेस का एक इनसिक्योर वर्जन पाया गया
है अगर आप देखेंगे तो यहां पे आपको दिख
रहा होगा
5.6.3 जो है ये वल्नरेबल होगी 110 पर तो
मैं यहां पे इसको एक बार कॉपी कर लेता हूं
एंड मैं आपको एक चीज दिखा देता हूं यहां
पे करते हैं वर्डप्रेस
5.6.3 एंड एक्सप्लोइट्स व बिलिटी कर लेते
हैं व बिलिटी तो यहां पर आपको व बिलिटी
मिल चुकी है डब्ल्यूपी स्न की वेबसाइट प
ही अगर आप देखेंगे कि यहां पर 5.6.3 की
वने बिलिटी है एंड 5.6.3 की जो वने बिलिटी
है यह 1 5.6
पॉइंट यह वाली यह देखो यहां पर लेस देन 5
5.5 में यह आ रही है
अ यहां
पे यह सारी यह जो वले एबिलिटीज है आपकी
यहां पे 5 प मान लो 6 में वल बटीज है तो
5.6.3 के पहले के जो भी वर्जन आपको
मिलेंगे ठीक है यहां पे आप देख सकते हो
यहां पे ऑब्जेक्ट इंजेक्शन इन पीएचपी मेलर
ये आपको यहां पे मिलने को देखने को मिल
जाएगा यहां पे और भी जाएंगे यहां पे और भी
बहुत सारी आपको मिल जाएंगी मल्टीपल
एबिलिटीज वगैरह मिल जाएंगी यहां पे दे यू
कैन फाइंड मल्टीपल वलने बिलिटी ठीक है तो
यहां पे मैं ओपन कर लेता हूं यहां पे 5.6
एक वलने बिलिटी 5.6 6.3 तक जो है पीएचपी
ऑब्जेक्ट इंजेक्शन जो अवेलेबिलिटी है
जिसकी बात हम कर रहे थे वही यहां पे वर्जन
यहां पे आ रहा है वर्डप्रेस इज़ प्रोन टू
अवेलेबिलिटी दैट लेट्स रिमोट अटैकर्स
इंजेक्ट एंड एग्जीक्यूट आर्बिट्री कोड
बिकॉज़ द एप्लीकेशन फेल्स टू सैनिटाइज
यूज़र सप्लाइड इनपुट बिफोर बीइंग पास्ड टू
द अ अनसीरियस पीएचपी फंक्शन अनसीरियस है
दैट्ची है अब यहां पे अगर देखो अब ये
सेल्फ एक्सप्लोरेशन क्या होता है अन सरिज
पीएपी फंक्शन यहां पे अनसीरियस पीएचपी
फंक्शन ये हम करेंगे यहां पे एंटर कर
देंगे अब यहां पे एंटर करने पे क्या आ रहा
है अनसीरियस टेक्स अ सिंगल सीरियलिज्ड
वेरिएबल एंड कन्वर्ट्स बैक इनटू अ पीएचपी
वैल्यू ठीक है ना डों डू नॉट पास
अनट्रस्टेड यूज़र इनपुट टू अनसीरियस
रिगार्डलेस ऑफ़ द ऑप्शन अ वैल्यू ऑफ अलाउड
क्लासेस तो यानी कि ये एक वल्नरेबल है जो
इसके अंदर में पाई गई है ठीक है यहां
रेफरेंस के लिए आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
गिट हप पे एंड वर्डप्रेस सपोर्ट दोनों
यहां मिला हुआ है गिट पे आप जाएंगे तो
वहां पे इसका एक्सप्लोइट होगा बट यहां पे
हटा दिया गया है बट यहां पे सिंपल सा हम
इस चीज में देख लेते हैं यहां पे इस चीज
में देख लेते हैं यहां पे सिक्योरिटी
अपडेट्स यहां पे दी गई है यहां पे अ देयर
आर ये वाली लिस्ट ऑफ फाइल्स रिवाइज जो यह
जो फाइल में अवेलेबिलिटीज थी वो ये थी पीप
मेलर phpmailerautoload.php
मिली है इनको ये एक ओल्ड वर्जन मिली है
ठीक है बढ़िया बात है एंड यहां पे वर्जन
है 5.4.6 चलिए तो ये एक वल्नरेबल प्लग इन
हो सकता है जेएस कंपोजर के लिए उसके बाद
यहां पे रिवोल्यूशन स्लाइडर यहां पे मिली
है लेटेस्ट वर्जन 6.7.1 है एंड यहां पे भी
जो है इसका जो वर्जन है ये बहुत ही पुराना
है 5.4.3 तो अगर कोई रिवोल्यूशन स्लाइडर
या अगर कोई जेस कंपोजर इन प्लगिंस के अंदर
कोई एक्स वनबिल है एंड कोई एक्सप्लोइट
अवेलेबल है तो इसके थ्रू इस वेबसाइट को
एक्सप्लोइट किया जाता सकता है व कॉमर्स व
कमर्स की जो है यह वर्जन है 4.1.0 जबकि
लेटेस्ट 9.1.2 है अब खुद सोचो यहां पे अब
मैं क्या करता हूं वर्जन 100% कॉन्फिडेंस
है ये तो मैं व कॉमर्स का ना एक बार एक
बार ऐसे ट्राई आपको कर लेना है इस तरीके
से व
कॉमर्स
4.1.0 एक्सप्लोइट चलो एक्सप्लोइट देख लेते
हैं डायरेक्ट कि कोई एक्सप्लोइट अवेलेबल
है क्या लेबिलिटी इन 4.1 1.0 क्रिटिकल वटी
डिटेक्टेड इन ठीक है एक बार यह देख लेते
हैं यह देख लेते हैं यह देख लेते हैं ठीक
है यहां पे आ रहा
है कौन सी वर्जन है पहले ये देख लेते हैं
ऑटोमेटिक सफ डेट टू बिफोर ंग डेट ठीक है
फॉर व कमर्स दिस इज फाइ और हाईएस्ट नंबर
पॉसिबल इट ठीक है विद द रिलीज ऑफ व कमर्स
ऑटो अपडेट्स यहां पे बिफोर यू सड यूजिंग
आल्सो इफ यू आर रनिंग कमर्स ब्लॉक यू शुड
बी यूजिंग 5.4 5.1 बट यहां पे हमें किस
चीज के लिए पे आ रहा है यहां पे यहां पे
ओल्ड वर्जन है 4.1.0
तो
4.1.0 यह वाली 4.1.1 है यहां पे ठीक
है एक लेबिलिटी इसके अंदर में है यहां
पे यह पैच हो चुकी है एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन
इन व कमर्स प्लगइन एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन भी
एक पाई गई है एंड क्रिटिकल यहां पे एक व
कमर्स ब्लॉक प्लगइन में यहां पे पाई गई है
इंप्रोपर एक्सेस कंट्रोल पाया गया है
क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग पाई गई है तो यह
सारी चीजें विथ एक्सप्लोइट अगर देखते हैं
यहां पे तो मान लो स्क इंजेक्शन ये वाली
यह वाली एक बार देख लेते हैं पैच हो चुकी
है क्रिटिकल है पैच अवेलेबल
है ठीक है यहां पे यह वाली लेबिलिटी है
यहां पे एक्सप्लोइट अवेलेबल है यहां पे
एंड व कॉमर्स 4 3.3.0 से 5.5.0 तक
वल्नरेबल था तो यहां पे ये एक्स अवेलेबल
है यहां पे एक्सप्लॉयड ऑफ यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे ये एक्सप्लोइट यहां पे
अवेलेबल है क्रिटिकल अवेलेबिलिटी पाई गई
यहां पे एंड दिस वन इज इसका चलिए इसको एक
बार ओपन कर लेते हैं इंप्रोपर
न्यूट्रलाइजेशन ऑफ स्पेशल एस यूज इन ए
एसकल कमांड तो यहां पे इसके एक्सप्लॉयड
अवेलेबल है अब हम यहां पे ना क्या करेंगे
हम इसको ट्राई कर सकते हैं एक्सप्लोइट
करने का चलिए अब एक काम कर लेते हैं
एक्सप्लोइट करने से पहले एक काम कर लेते
हैं यहां पे हमें यहां पे तो सब कुछ पता
चल गया भैया हमने क्या कमांड हमने क्या
कमांड रन किया था सॉरी हमने यहां पे कमांड
रन किया था
एी ऑल प्लगिंस हम यहां पे ऑल प्लगिंस
इनमेट किए थे अब हम यहां पे क्या करेंगे
यहां पे वल्नरेबल प्लगिंस सिर्फ हम इनमेट
करेंगे और एंटर करेंगे लेट्स सी तो हमने
एंटर
किया चलिए तो यहां पे जैसे ही हमने यहां
पे एंटर किया अब यहां पे आ रहा है कि नो
प्लगिंस फाउंड हमने जब वीपी वल्नरेबल
प्लगिंस किया ना तो यहां पे आ रहा है कि
नो प्लगिंस फाउंड तो ये कई बार होता है कई
बार प्रॉब्लम ये वाली चीज आती है कि नो
प्लगिंस फाउंड क्योंकि वल्नरेबल प्लगइन को
लग रहा है कि नहीं है बट स्टिल हमारे पास
जो प्लगिंस ओल्डर वर्जन के आ रहे हैं ना
तो वो ओल्डर वर्जन के प्लगिंस जो हैं वो
ऑलरेडी वल्नरेबल हो सकते हैं तो आपको
फाइंड करना है कि ओल्ड वर्जन का कुछ है
क्या अब मान लो आपको ये सब कुछ नहीं करना
लेट्स सपोज इसको कुछ नहीं करना तो आप क्या
कर सकते हैं भैया इसको कुछ मत डालो कोई भी
ऑप्शन मत डालो सीधा व डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन हान
आन यूआरएल ये हर एक चीज आपको डिटेल में
प्रोवाइड कर देगा आउटपुट में तो चलिए वेट
करते हैं अब आउटपुट देखिए इसका एक डिटेल
आउटपुट आपको मिलने वाला है बहुत ही डिटेल
आउटपुट देखिए वेट करते
हैं देखते जाओ डिटेल आउटपुट मिलेगा
आपको जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट चलिए यहां पे आ चुका है यहां पे डिटेल
आउटपुट अगेन सेम यहां पे एक नरेट कॉन्फिन
बैकअप्स भी आ रहा था यहां पे एंड और भी
चीजें यहां पे आ रहा है नो डब्ल्यूपी
स्कैन एपीआई टोकन गिवन एज अ रिजल्ट वलने
बिलिटी डेटा हैज नॉट बीन आउटपुट वलने
बिलिटी डटा आउटपुट नहीं मिली है यहां पे
क्या कर रहा है यू कैन रजिस्टर अ फ्री
एपीआई टोकन विथ 25 डेली रिक्वेस्ट बाय
रजिस्टरिंग एकट आप इस पे जाके ना आप इसको
रजिस्टर कर सकते हैं एक एपीआई लेने के लिए
और कुछ बात नहीं है तो वो आपकी भाई वो है
मर्जी है आप चाहे तो यहां पे रजिस्टर
कीजिए और यहां पे एपीआई ले लीजिए और यहां
पे आपको देखने को अगर मिलेगा तो मैं यहां
पे डब्ल्यूपी
स्कैन डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन हाइन एच एंटर करता
हूं मैं यहां पे आ जाते यहां पे एंड लेट्स
सी यह
रहा यहां पे यह वाली आपको फंक्शनल ये वाला
आपको आर्गुमेंट यूज करना है हा एपीआई हाई
फन टोकन ठीक है ना तो ये वाला आपको देना
है उसके बाद टोकन आपको देता है डब्ल्यूपी
स् एपीआई टू डिस्प्ले लेबिलिटी डाटा
अवेलेबल एट डब्ल्यूपी scan.com
प्रोफाइल तो ये वाली आपको दे देनी है भैया
तो आपका जो प्रोफाइल लेबिलिटी वाली
प्रोफाइल जो डाटा है वो भी आ जाएगी तो आप
चाहे तो कर सकते हैं नहीं चाहे तो नहीं कर
सकते तो चलिए आपको मैं यहां पे दिखा देता
हूं एक बार लेट्स गो
अप सेम कमांड हम जैसे हमने रन किया था
यहां पे लेट्स रन
आएगी यार सब आएगी
आएगी सब आएगी
ठीक
है यहां पर आ
गया अब यहां पर जब तुम डिटेल में अभी
रिजल्ट आएगा तो देखते हैं अभी जस्ट वेट
गाइस आ गया अब यहां पे आओगे तो लेबिलिटी
वाली नहीं आई है क्योंकि हमें इस वाले पाथ
प जाना है तो मैं लिंक एड्रेस को कॉपी कर
लेता हूं एंड यहां पे लिंक एड्रेस को ओपन
करके यहां पे ओपन कर लेते हैं ब्राउजर के
अंदर में ठीक है तो यहां पर डब्ल्यूपी
स्कन प आपको साइन अप करना पड़ता है सिंपल
सा फंडा है ये ठीक है तो चलिए साइन अप कर
लेते हैं टेंप मेल का यूज कर लेते हैं पता
ही है कि हम हर जगह टेंप मेल यूज करेंगे
नेम देते यहां पर नेम मैं दे देता
हूं नितेश ईमेल आईडी देते हैं एक टेंपररी
ईमेल आईडी शायद यह ले ले कोई दिक्कत ना हो
तो एक ईमेल आईडी दे देते
हैं अच्छी बात है पासवर्ड दे देते हैं
सिक्स कैरेक्टर्स
मिनिमम तो हमने पासवर्ड दे
दिया एंड यहां अग्री कर देते हैं एंड यहां
पर रजिस्टर कर लेते हैं
मैसेज विथ कंफर्मेशन लिंक हैज बीन सेंट
योर ईमेल आईडी बहुत अच्छी बात है यहां पर
एक मेल आएगा आपके कन्फर्मेशन का तो इस मेल
को आने देते
हैं कंफर्म योर अकाउंट तो चलिए कंफर्म कर
लेते हैं अकाउंट कंफर्म माय अकाउंट तो
क्लिक कर लेते हैं अरे अरे यहीं से ओपन हो
गया क्या ठीक है चलिए कंफर्मिंग योर
अकाउंट एंड अकाउंट इज
कंफर्म नाउ अब यहां पर लॉगइन कर लेते हैं
अगेन सेम ईमेल आईडी डाल देते हैं मैं ईमेल
आईडी तो भूल ही क्योंकि ईमेल आईडी मैंने
वो चेंज कर दिया था तो ईमेल आईडी मैं यहां
पर डाल देता हूं ताकि मेरे को याद रहे
मतलब यह पता रहे हमें यही वाली मिल जाए
हमें पासवर्ड यहां पे डाल देते हैं जो
हमने पासवर्ड डाला था एंड यहां पे लॉगइन
कर लेते हैं ठीक है लॉगइन करने के बाद
यहां पे हमें एक एपीआई की मिलनी चाहिए एक
टोकन नंबर एपीआई टोकन यह कॉपी कर लेते हैं
एंड अब जो है हम अगर रिक्वेस्ट डालते हैं
ना अब जब हम यहां पे चीजें करते हैं तो हम
यहां पे डब्ल्यूपी हान h पे हमने देखा था
एपीआई टोकन वाली जो जो हमारी थी वो क्या
थी भैया हमारा ऑप्शन हाइन हाइन
एपीआई कहां गया भाई वेयर इज द एपीआई एपीआई
कहां
है अरे यार ऐसे कैसे कर रहे हो ऐसे कैसे
हो रहा है कभी-कभी क्या होता है एपीआई य
यहां है हाई फन हाई फन एपीआई हाई फन टोकन
ठीक है हाई फन हा फन एपीआई हान टोकन हम
यहां पे कर देते हैं तो हम यहां पे सेम
कमांड डालते हैं यहां पे हान हान एपीआई
एंड हान टोकन लगा के एंड यहां पे हम अपना
जो टोकन है यहां पे वो मेंशन कर देते हैं
और अब हम एंटर करेंगे तो हमने एपीआई की जो
है या एपीआई टोकन जो है हमने दे दिया है
याद रखिएगा 25 रिक्वेस्ट ही है ओनली तो
देखते हैं कि लेबिलिटी रिपोर्ट हमारे पास
आती है किस तरीके से आती है ठीक है हमारे
पास आ चुकी है गाइस हमारे पास आ रही है
गाइस वटी की रिपोर्ट दिस इज द पावर ऑफ
एपीआई तो हमारे पास वनरे बिटी रिपोर्ट आ
रही है और आ चुकी है ऑलरेडी अगर आपको नहीं
पता आपको दिख रहा है वलन बिलिटी रिपोर्ट
आई है ऊपर कि नहीं आई है बताइए मुझे मुझे
बताइए वनबिल रिपोर्ट आई है कि
नहीं बताइए मुझे लेबिलिटी रिपोर्ट ऊपर
आपको आई है कि नहीं आई है मुझे ये बताइए
देख के देख के लग रहा है कहीं
पे जल्दी बताइए रितिक क्या कर रहे हो या
एक सिंबल बार-बार दे रहे हो बार-बार दे
रहे
हो बारबार मत करो ठीक
है सर आपके साथ-साथ कर रहा हूं बहुत मस्त
बहुत बढ़िया बहुत टाइम से आपकी वीडियो देख
रहा हूं इसलिए आई हैव सम होप फ्रॉम यू
बहुत
बढ़िया बहुत टाइम से डाउट पूछ रहा हूं भाई
डाउट पर मैं अभी ध्यान नहीं दे रहा हूं
सिद्धांत मंडल अभी मैं डाउट पर ध्यान नहीं
दे रहा हूं अभी मैं इधर पढ़ा रहा हूं डाउट
पे ज्यादा फोकस नहीं कर सकता ड्यूरिंग द
क्लासेस द टारगेट अपीयर्स टू बी होस्टेड
ऑन wordpress.com स्कैनिंग सच साइट इज नॉट
सपोर्टेड तब से क्या आ रहा है मेरा एरर आ
रहा है कि स्कैनिंग फ्रॉम डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन
स्कैन अटेड टारगेट अपीयर्स टू बी होस्टेड
ऑन वर्डप्रेस
कॉ नहीं आपने फिर सही से नहीं किया है सही
से कुछ ना कुछ प्रॉब्लम्स है ओके ठीक है
अब देखो जैसे हमने एपीआई कॉन्फिन के अंदर
में हमारे पास अब वलने बिलिटी रिपोर्ट भी
आने लगी है अब ये वलने बिलिटी रिपोर्ट
क्या है आप देखिए य कितनी सारी वलने
बिलिटी रिपोर्ट आई है आप सोच नहीं सकते यह
देखो ना यार
देखो बाप रे ओ माय गॉड ओ माय गॉड यह कितना
डिटेल आया हुआ है भाई यह देखो पहले कुछ
नहीं आ रहा था अभी
देखो आरपी स्कैन तो ठीक है यह सब ठीक है
अब य पर रेड वाले में आओ 42 व बिलिटी
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
वेबसाइट है फट forest.in अब
बताओ लाइव वेबसाइट है भाई यह डेमो नहीं है
42 वले
एबिलिटीज समझ रहे
हो अब यहां पे टाइटल वर्डप्रेस
3.72 5 प पहले तो वर्डप्रेस की ही है
ऑब्जेक्ट इंजेक्शन इन पीएचपी मेलर जिसकी
मैं बात आपसे कर रहा था यह वही
अवेलेबिलिटी है जिसकी मैंने थोड़ी देर
पहले बात की थी जो हमने देखा था ऑब्जेक्ट
इंजेक्शन इन पीएचपी मेलर जिसकी वजह से
आर्बिट्री कोड को एग्जीक्यूट किया जा सकता
है भाई यानी कि कमांड इंजेक्शन भी हो सकती
है समझ में आ रहा है रेफरेंस के लिए फिक्स
ये फिक्स कर दिया गया था
5.6.4 में लेकिन इनका वर्जन क्या है इन
फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट लोगों का वर्जन क्या है ये
भी तो देखना है 5.6.4 में फिक्स हुआ था ये
इनका 5.6.3 है यानी कि ये इनका वल्नरेबल
है भाई वल्नरेबल कैसे है तो अभी देखोगे
तुम यहां पे मिरे ओजी पे आप जाओगे तो आपकी
यहां पे इसकी अवेलेबिलिटी की पूरी डिटेल
जो है यहां पे इसकी मिल जाएगी या फिर आप
wps.com पे भी जाओगे तो इसकी पूरी की पूरी
पीएचपी ऑब्जेक्शन वाली जो लेबिलिटी की
डिटेल है यहां पे आपको मिल जाएगी एंड यहां
पे आपको अगेन यहां पे इसका अ जो रेफरेंस
है वह सारा रेफरेंस जो है यहां पे मिल रहा
है यह आप देख सकते हैं गाइस देख सकते हैं
यहां पे यहां पे एक वीडियो भी है यहां पे
वीडियो भी है मैनुअली क्राफ्टिंग पीएचपी
गैजेट करके इनको एक्सप्लोइट करने का एंड
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं रिलीज नोट य यहां
पे आई हुई है एंड यहां पे एवरीथिंग हैज
बीन डन तो यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
क्या-क्या चीजें हटाई गई हैं एंड
क्या-क्या चीजें ऐड की गई है इस वलने
बिलिटी को फिक्स करने के लिए तो चलिए मेन
वेबसाइट में लेबिलिटी है अब यहां पे आ
जाते हैं और भी यहां पे
youtube0 अब यहां पे वर्डप्रेस का ही एक
अवेलेबिलिटी है डाटा एक्सपोजर वाय रेस्ट
एपीआई एंड यहां पे अगेन इसके जो डिटेल्स
है यहां पे दिए गए हैं अलग-अलग रेफरेंसेस
दिए गए हैं इन रेफरेंसेस पे जाके आप इनको
जो है पढ़ सकते हैं इनको जो है आप देख
सकते हैं कि आखिर इसके बीच में क्या है
ठीक
है यह चीज देख सकते हैं अब चलिए यहां पे
आप आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको सारी डिटेल जो
है इसके रिगार्डिंग जो है मिलेगी वट प्रेस
इजर फ्री डिस्क्रिप्शन दिया हुआ है यहां
पे क्या किस तरीके से क्या प्रॉब्लम है
भाई किस तरीके से क्या है रेफरेंसेस यहां
पे अलग-अलग रेफरेंसेस दिए गए हैं तो आप
रेफरेंसेस देख सकते हैं यहां पे कुछ इस
तरीके से यहां पे हैकर वन के रिपोर्ट्स भी
दिए गए हैं तो आप हैकर वन के अगर
रिपोर्ट्स पढ़ेंगे तो आपको यहां पे उसका
भी आईडिया लग जाएगा कि अगर किसी ने
अवेलेबिलिटी फाइंड की है तो भैया यहां पे
आपको उसका डिटेल जो है यहां पे मिल जाएगा
ठीक है तो यहां पे ये साइन इन करने के लिए
बोल रहे हैं बट यह ऐसा मैं कॉपी लिंक कर
लेता हूं कॉपी लिंक कॉपी लिंक कहां है
कॉपी लिंक कॉपी लिंक करके एंड मैं ना इसको
ब्राउजर में ओपन कर लेता हूं यहां से ओपन
कर लेता हूं सिंपल तो यहां ओपन हो जाना
चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से यू नीड टू साइन इन
बिफोर कंटिन्यूइंग ऐसे क्या यार दिमाग का
वो कर रहे हो फिर पासवर्ड ही नहीं होगा
चलो कोई बात नहीं तो हैकर वन के रिपोर्ट
है आप इसको देख लीजिएगा देयर इज अ हैकर वन
रिपोर्ट आल्सो ऑन बेस्ड ऑन दिस वले
एबिलिटीज ठीक है तो यहां पे आपको इसके मिल
रही है अब यहां पे देखिए यहां पे अ जस्ट
क्लोज इट क्लोज इट क्लोज इट क्लोज
इट यहां पे आ रहा है वर्डप्रेस का
ऑथेंटिकेटेड एक्सेसेस इन ब्लॉक एडिटर यहां
भैया एक्सेसेस है ब्लॉक एडिटर के अंदर में
ब्लॉक एडिटर में क्या है भैया एक्सेसेस है
ठीक है तो यहां पे इसके पूरी डिटेल्स है
यहां पे किस तरीके से आप इसको पढ़ लीजिएगा
उसके बाद लोडश लाइब्रेरी अपडेट का एक
अवेलेबिलिटी है इस वर्जन में वर्डप्रेस के
तो यहां पे आप इसकी रेफरेंस को चेक आउट
करके पढ़ सकते हैं एक्सपायर डीएसटी रूट
cx3 सर्टिफिकेट का एक एक्स वनबिल यहां पे
है इसको आप यहां पे देख सकते हैं उसके बाद
नीचे आते हैं यहां पे प्लगइन कंफ्यूजन
यहां पे लेस दन 5.8 में यहां पे है
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन वाया डब्ल्यूपी क्वेरी
अब यहां पे आप देखो यहां पे एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन भी है लेस दन 5.8.3 वर्जन में
भाई एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन है वट प्रेस की
वेबसाइट्स पे इट मींस दिस वर्डप्रेस
वेबसाइट फ्रूट क्या कौन सी वेबसाइट है भाई
ये फ्रूट फॉर फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट फूट फॉस्ट आ
इज आल्सो वल्नरेबल टू एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन
जी हां इसके में एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन
लेबिलिटी भी एजिस्ट करती है बेसिकली आप इस
तरीके से रिपोर्ट भी तैयार कर सकते हैं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं हां जी हां जी व हां वन
वलनर से भी आप कर सकते हैं बिल्कुल
सिद्धांत सिद्धांत बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं
बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं अभी तो बस माइंडसेट
डेवलप करनी है माइंड सेट डेवलप करना है कि
भाई क्या किस तरीके से हो रही है ऑथर प्लस
स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस वाया पोस्ट स्लग्स यहां
पे एक वलने एबिलिटी यहां पे दी गई है यहां
पे आपकी आ रही है यहां पे हैकर वन का एक
रिपोर्ट है यहां पे स्टोर्ड एक्सेस
लेबिलिटी है यहां पे एक हैकर वन का
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन का रिपोर्ट है यहां पे
आप ये देख सकते हैं ठीक है बहुत अच्छी बात
है सुपर एडमिन ऑब्जेक्ट इंजेक्शन यहां पे
एक मिल रही है यहां पे रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस
साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग मिल रही है भाई
रिफ्लेक्टेड क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग यहां
पे आपको मिल रही है ठीक है देयर आर
मल्टीपल अवेलेबिलिटीज जो वर्डप्रेस की अ
वर्जंस का यह पूरा पूरा वर्डप्रेस के
वर्जन का ये है भाई देख लो उसके बाद अब बा
आते हैं नीचे की तरफ कुछ और मिलो यार
सिर्फ वर्डप्रेस ही अब देखो यहां पे जेएस
कंपोजर वाले में भी वलने बिलिटी है अब
देखो सेवन वलने बिलिटी आइडेंटिफिकेशन
अ अ डब्ल्यूपी बेकरी यहां पे आ रहा है
डब्ल्यूपी यहां पे अवेलेबिलिटी एक्सपोज्ड
देखो 4 मिलियन साइट्स ये जो वनबिल थी 4
मिलियन साइट्स को एक्सपोज किया था इसने
बहुत ही शानदार वलने बिलिटी थी भाई
डब्ल्यूपी स्टोर्ड एक्सेस एस वाली यहां पे
अगेन यहां पे और भी वले एबिलिटीज है
डब्ल्यूपी बेकरी वाली यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं अभी इसी की चल रही है यहां पे
रिवोल्यूशन यहां पे एक और है यहां पे अ
दिस इज 11 वनबिल आइडेंटिफिकेशन
दिस इज रिवोल्यूशन स्लाइडर में यहां पे
आपको वनरे बिलिटी मिल रही है ऑथर प्लस
रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन अब देखो यहां पे यह
रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन है भैया इसमें यह
देख सकते हो यहां पे स्लाइडर इवोल्यूशन
में रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन मिल रही है
आपको अब क्या चाहिए यार अब क्या चाहिए ट
अब हमें यहां पे ना इनके एक्सप्लोइट्स
खोजने हैं चलो अब हमें क्या करना है इनके
एक्सप्लोइट्स खोजने है खोजने है ना भाई ये
तो हमें वने बिलिटी मिल गई अलग-अलग वने
बिलिटी हमें मिल रही है राइट वी आर गेटिंग
वने बिलिटी बट हमें एक्स एक्सट खोजना है
वो एक्सप्लोइट कैसे खोजो बताओ मुझे हाउ यू
विल फाइंड दोज एक्सप्लोइट्स
लेट मी
टेल
बताइए बताइए मुझे एक्सप्लोइट कैसे खोजें
आप सर्च स्पॉट सीवी के थ्रू फ्रॉम गिटर
ठीक है हां ठीक
है ठीक है देर आर मल्टीपल वेज टू फाइंड
एक्सप्लोइट्स एक्सप्लोइट डीबी पे भी आप जा
सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं एक्सप्लोइट डीबी
पे भी जाके आप जो है सर्च कर सकते हैं एक
और तरीका है जो मैं आपको यहां पे बता देता
हूं चलिए मैं यहां पे कंट्रोल शिफ्ट
कंट्रोल टी करके सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी
कंट्रोल शिफ्टी एक नया टैब ओपन कर लेता
हूं मैं यहां पे एक टूल का यूज करने जा
रहा हूं जिस टूल का नाम है सीएमएस मैप
बहुत ही शानदार टूल है सीएमएस मैप
ठीक है सीएमएस मैप टूल का हम यूज़ करने
वाले हैं व्हाट दिस टूल इज एक्चुअली आप
देख सकते हैं यहां पे सीएमएस मैप इज अ
पाइथन ओपन सो बहुत सारे जो हंटर्स इसको
यूज़ करते हैं बहुत ऑलरेडी ओपन सोर्स
सीएमएस स्कैनर द दैट ऑटोमेट द प्रोसेस ऑफ
डिटेक्टिंग सिक्योरिटी फ्लज ऑफ़ मोस्ट ऑफ़
द पॉपुलर सीएमएस द मेन पर्पस ऑफ़ द सीएमएस
इज टू इंटीग्रेट कॉमन लेबिलिटी ऑफ़
डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ़ सीएमएस इन अ सिंगल टूल
एट द मोमेंट सीएमएस मैप सपोर्टेड आर्
वर्डप्रेस जूमला ध्रुप एंड मोडल ठीक है तो
भैया इसको इंस्टॉल करना मतलब इसको
कॉन्फिनेट गिट क्लोन कर लेना है हमें
सिंपल सा क्या है यहां पे गिट क्लोन कर
लेते हैं गेट क्लोन एंड सीएमएस मैप ठीक है
गेट क्लोन कर
लीजिए सीएमएस मैप में चल जाते हैं सीडी
सीएस सीएमएस सीएमएस अरे यार क्या हो रहा
है सीएमएस मैप एलएस कर लेते हैं यहां पे
ये सारी फाइल्स हैं इसमें आपको कहीं पे भी
कुछ और मिल रहा है क्या सीएमएस मैप एक एक
ये डायरेक्टरी मिली है ठीक है c
अ एप्ट काली के लिए आपको एक यहां पे एप्ट
जो यूज करते हैं तो काली के लिए यहां पे
क्या है कि यह बोल रहे हैं कि आपको एक
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल है कौन सी कॉन्फिन
लिस्ट से चेक करेंगे एक्सप्लोइट डीबी तो
यह ऑटोमेटिक इंस्टॉल्ड होता है
क्या नहीं नहीं ऑटोमेटेड नहीं है तो इसको
आप इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं जिनका इंस्टॉल
नहीं होगा एप्ट इंस्टॉल एक्सप्लोइट डीबी
ठीक है एप्ट इंस्टॉल एक्सप्लोइट डीबी कर
लीजिएगा यहां पे ये इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा ठीक
है अ यह अपग्रेडेड का आ रहा है ऑलरेडी
मेरा इंस्टॉल्ड है मेरा ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड
है इसलिए ये अपग्रेडेड का मांग रहा है और
कोई बात नहीं है ठीक है तो यहां मेरा
एक्सडी भी इंस्टॉल्ड है ऑलरेडी इसको आप
सर्च कर सकते हैं लोकेट कर सकते सकते हैं
तो आपका आ जाएगा लोकेट करके तो बेसिकली ये
कहां रहता है सीडीयस आर स् शेर एंड स्
एक्स डीवी यहां पे आपको मिल जाएगा एलएस के
अंदर आपको एक्सट डीवी की पूरी डिटेल्स
यहां प मिल जाएगी ठीक है भैया तो यहां मैं
चल देता हूं फिर से सीडी सीएमएस मैप य
एलएस कर लेते हैं हम इस पर आ चुके हैं हां
जी अब यहां पे इसकी कॉन्फिन फाइल चेक कर
लेते हैं तो सीडी सीएमएस मैप में चलना है
एंड यहां एंटर एलस करेंगे तो एक कॉन्फिन
फाइल है cms.com इसको कर लेंगे तो vc.com
इसको ओपन करेंगे तो इसके अंदर वो
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन होनी चाहिए तो ऑलरेडी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है यहां पे एक्सप्लोइट डीबी
एडिट यहां पे एक्सप्लोइट डेटाबेस टाइप
यहां पे एटी है एक्सप्लोइट डेटाबेस पाथ जो
है यूएसआर शेयर एक्सप्लोइट डी भी ऑलरेडी
यहां पे मेंशन है तो आपको कुछ करना ही
नहीं है अब आपको यहां से बाहर आ जाना है
इस डायरेक्टरी से सीएमए मैप के अंदर में
और यहां पे पिप 3 से इंस्टॉलेशन कर लेनी
है पिप थ इंस्टॉल एंड डॉट लगा देनी है तो
ऑटोमेटिक वो इंस्टॉलेशन जो है पिप थ वाली
इंस्टॉल स्टार्ट कर देगा तो यहां पे हमारी
इंस्टॉलेशन हो चुकी है अब हम सीएमए में प
को डायरेक्ट यूज कर लेंगे न s देंगे सॉरी
सीएमएस मैप जो है स्टार्ट हो जाएगा बस
सीएमएस मैप को अब यूज कर लेंगे टारगेट को
हंट करने के लिए तो क्या करना है भैया
यहां पे टारगेट यूआरएल देना है यहां पे
सिंपल चलिए तो इसको यूज कर यूज केसेस क्या
है इसका यह देख लेते हैं तो यहां पे क्या
करना है सीएमएस मैप एंड इसके बाद सिंपल सा
आपका जो डोमेन है वो डोमेन आप दे दीजिए
ठीक है तो चलिए हम डोमेन दे देते हैं यहां
पे तो
सीएमएस मैप एंड यहां पर हम डोमेन देते हैं
हमारा डोमेन है यह
वाला हमने कॉपी कर लिया एंड हमने यहां पर
डोमेन दे दिया चलिए ठीक है एंटर कर देते
हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इ हैपनिंग तो यहां पर आ
रहा है एक्सप्लो डीबी एंड सीएमएस मैप
प्लगइन आर नॉट अपडेटेड टू द लेटेस्ट वर्जन
वड यू लाइक टू अपडेट इट अरे यार यह क्या
है यस देखते हैं इसको अपडेट करता है कितना
टाइम लगाता है
एक मिनट मैं इसको क्लोज करता हूं मैं य पर
न्यू टैब में करके यहां पर प अपडेट पहले
चलाने दो
मुझे प अपडेट चला देते
पहले यह जरूरी होता है गाइस यह काम आप
जरूर कर
लीजिएगा आई एम इन 11थ लर्निंग फ्रॉम यू
ग्रेट हार्ड वर्क एंड वी ल रिस्पेक्ट योर
डेडिकेशन धन्यवाद भाई बहुत बहुत
धनवाद चलिए तो यहां हो चुका यहां पर एंड
अब ए अपग्रेड कमांड चला देते हैं एट
अपग्रेड तो यहां मैं प् अपग्रेड करके
अपग्रेड कर देता हूं जो भी आप इसमें
एक्सप्लोइट डीब भी होगा अपग्रेड वाले में
देखो जरा है क्या एक्सप्लोइट डीबी ई वाले
ई में
ई बी सी डी ई ई में होगा शायद यार एक्सडी
क्योंकि हां यह रहा एक्सप्लोइट डीबी यह है
यह अपडेट हो रहा है अपग्रेड हो रहा है तो
वी आर अपग्रेडिंग है ना हां जी बिल्कुल
बढ़िया है भाई बिल्कुल बढ़िया है ठीक है
तो वी आर अपग्रेडिंग
इट सो लेट्स
वेट हां जी भैया हां जी भैया बताइए इसको
अपग्रेड हो जाने देते हैं इसको लेट्स लेट
इट अपग्रेड
लेट इट
अपग्रेड चलिए यहां पे 82 पर हो चुका है
हां
[संगीत]
जी बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल होने देते
हैं हाउ एक्सएमएल आरपीसी कराएंगे भाई वो
भी कराएंगे
वो भी एक्सएमएल आरपीसी वाला भी पार्ट कवर
करूंगा इस इस वनरे बिलिटी का एक और पार्ट
वीडियो आएगा एक और एक वीडियो में एक क्लास
में कवर नहीं हो पाएगा गाइस तो मतलब एक और
पार्ट में ला दूंगा ना क्योंकि उसमें
एक्सएल आरपीसी और वर्डप्रेस की अलग और भी
जो
डिफरेंट जो तरीके हैं टेक्निक्स है वह मैं
आपको बताऊंगा और भी है बहुत कुछ है अभी तो
तो अगर आपको चाहिए तो एक और वीडियो में ला
दूंगा
आज एडवर्टाइजमेंट नहीं आई अभी तक अरे यार
य तो बड़ी बुरी बात है यार एडवर्टाइजमेंट
नहीं आई अभी तक यह कैसे हो गया हा मुझे भी
नहीं दिखाया एडवर्टाइजमेंट ऐसा क्यों
यार क्या यार एडवर्टाइजमेंट नहीं आ रही आज
के वीडियो
पर तो
बड़ी प्रोब्लेमे िक चीज है एक
एडवर्टाइजमेंट मैं एडवर्टाइजमेंट ला दू
क्या रुको अभी मैं एडवर्टाइजमेंट लाता
हूं पांच आई है मैं अभी इसने बोला
एडवर्टाइजमेंट नहीं आई एक
अभी अभी इसमें घुसाते हैं इसमें
एडवर्टाइजमेंट मैं खुद से डाल सकता हूं
क्या
यार इंसर्ट ड इंसर्ट ड आ रहा है यहां पर ड
आएगी क्या देखते हैं ऐड इंसर्टेड देखते
हैं ऐड आ रही है कि नहीं आ रही है ऐड आई
क्या
गाइस ऐड आ गई है
क्या आ गई देखा मैं खुद ही मैंने ऐड ला
दिया खुद से भी ऐड लाने का ऑप्शन दे दिया
इन लोगों ने ये अच्छी चीज है
यार यह अच्छी चीज है खुद से पहले ऐसा नहीं
होता
था नहीं आई मेरे तो आई यार
ऐड चलो यहां पे अपग्रेड हो चुका
है यहां पे अपग्रेड हो चुका है वी हैव अप
ग्रेडेड ऐड ब्लॉक एक्सटेंशन यूज करने
वाले
मतलब बहुत बुरा है ये बहुत बुरा बुरा कर
रहे हो ड एक्सटेंशन ड ब्लॉक वाले जो
एक्सटेंशन यूज करते हैं ना जनता माफ नहीं
करेगी तुम्हें कभी भी गलत बात है भाई
ये भगवान करे तुम्हारा व ड जो ड ब्लॉक
वाला एक्सटेंशन है उसमें कोई लेबिलिटी आ
जाए और एक्सप्लोइटेबल हो और तुम्हारे अंदर
एक हैकर घुसे तुम्हारे लैपटॉप के अंदर यह
मैं ऐसा बोल रहा हूं
तुमने ऐड को ब्लॉक किया है छोड़ेंगे नहीं
भाई
हम हां हां मेरे वीडियो के अलावा छोड़ कर
दो भाई कोई दिक्कत नहीं लव फ्रॉम
अफगानिस्तान लव फ्रॉम इंडिया ब्रदर लव
फ्रॉम
इंडिया अरे 62 पर हूं तो तो तुम्हारा खुद
का स्पीड है यार इट्स योर स्पीड बड़ी मैं
क्या
करूं सर हैकिंग से पहले वीपीएन यूज करना
चाहिए कि नहीं बिल्कुल करना चाहिए 110 पर
करना चाहिए वीपीएन हमेशा यूज करना चाहिए
मैं बोलता हूं अगर आप हैकिंग कर रहे हो ना
तो जब तक देखो टेस्टिंग वगैरह कर रहे हो
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है जहां पे आपको ऑलरेडी
परमिशन मिली हुई है पेन टेस्ट करने की
यानी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करने की वेबसाइट
पे एप्लीकेशन पे कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं कुछ
यूज मत करो बट अगर आप इलीगल कुछ करने की
कोशिश कर रहे हो मतलब जहां पे आपकी परमिशन
नहीं है यू वांट टू हाइड योर आइडेंटिटी
देन यू नीड अ वीपीएन सिंपल सा फंडा है यार
अपनी आइडेंटिटी हाइड करनी है ना ट्स
इट अभी अभी कुछ लोगों को ऐड नहीं आई थी
यार कुछ लोगों को ऐड नहीं आई थी उनको
अच्छा नहीं लग रहा पता है जिनको ऐड नहीं
आई थी वो बोल रहे कि सर मेरे को ऐड नहीं
आया सर सर मेरे पास ऐड नहीं आया यह कोई
बात हो गई
क्या मेरे को बोला कुछ लोगों ने कि सर
मेरे पास ऐड नहीं आई है
चलो यहां पर प्रोग्रेस हो रहा है थोड़ा
कुछ ज्यादा ही बड़ा अपडेट हो गया लग रहा
है यह आप लोग अपडेट एप्ट अपडेट एंड एप्ट
अपग्रेड हमेशा कीजिएगा कुछ कुछ टाइम पर
बढ़िया रहता है
य हाउ आई कैन स्टार्ट बग बाउंट फ्रॉम
स्क्रैच भाई अगर डेनिक्स अकेडमी के
वीडियोस देख रहे हो ना तुम तो तुम्हें सब
पता चल जाएगा बट वही ना प्रॉब्लम क्या है
ना कि बहुत सारे लोग वीडियोस पूरा देखते
ही नहीं है एकदम हर एक वीडियो डाली हुई है
इसी हिसाब से अभी और भी वीडियो रहेंगी तो
देखोगे तो मजा आ जाएगा टर यूज कर लो कोई
बात
नहीं क्लास और कितनी देर चलेगी ललित बस
थोड़ी देर और यार यह प्रोग्रेस में थोड़ा
टाइम लग रहा है थोड़ी देर और चलेगी उसके
बाद हो
जाएगा तो मैं यहां पे एक बार इसको चला के
देख लेता हूं शायद अब यहां पे यह कोई
प्रॉब्लम ना
आए मे बी यहां पे शायद अब जल्दी से हो जाए
तो पिप थ इंस्टॉल देख लेते एक बार अभी
शायद
अच्छा यह तो हो गया था ना यार इंस्टॉलेशन
तो हो चुकी थी ना इसकी सॉरी इसको स्टार्ट
करना था ओनली सॉरी सॉरी
सॉरी ये अगेन करेगा अब ये तो सीमस m फूट
फस्ट इसको स्टार्ट कर लेते
हैं हां अब ठीक है यह हो चुका अब शायद तो
यहां पे टारगेट यहां पे ले लिया फूट
forest.in इसकी आईपी हमारे पास आ चुकी है
सीएमएस मैप यहां पे आ चुका है एंड अब यहां
पे हमें रिजल्ट्स मिलना स्टार्ट हो रहे
हैं वी आर गेटिंग व आर स्टार्टिंग गेटिंग
रिजल्ट्स तो सीएमएस डिटेक्शन यहां पर आपको
दिख रहा होगा
कि र वी कैन
सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग यह क्या हो रहा
है तो चलो य यहां पे कुछ आया जो भी आया
कोई बात नहीं यहां पे कोई दिक्कत नहीं
यहां पे यहां पे वर्डप्रेस थीम आ रही है
ऑर्गेनाइज 243 यह इनका वर्डप्रेस थीम है
ऑर्गेनाइज 243 2.43 होगी शायद जो भी है या
24.3 भी हो सकती है कुछ भी हो सकता
है सो इसने थीम डिटेक्ट किया है ठीक है यह
अच्छी बात है इट डिटेक्टेड अ थीम
वर्डप्रेस
थीम ओके लेट्स वेट यह तो अपना चलता रहेगा
कोई बात नहीं इधर देखते हैं
एक्स एक्स इंजेक्शन नहीं हुआ है क्या एक्स
एक्स अच्छा ठीक है देखते हैं एक्सस अगर
नहीं हुआ तो
करेंगे ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके
ओके पार्ट टू इसका क्या लग रहा है आपको
पार्ट टू आना चाहिए क्या पार्ट टू आना
चाहिए जिसमें एक्सएमएल आरपीसी वगैरह कवर
करूं मैं या एक्सएमएल आरपीसी खुद ही कर
लोगे आप लोग बता दीजिए खुद ही कर लोगे या
मतलब मुझे करना मतलब मैं पार्ट टू वीडियो
लाकर उसमें डिटेल में बताऊं एक्सएमएल
आरपीसी का
पार्ट टू नीडेड पार्ट टू नीडेड
है नहीं करता मैं यार बक क्राउड पे
हंट बक क्राउड हैकर वन इन सब
पे आई एम नॉट अ फुल टाइम हंटर ऑलरेडी
टोल्ड मैंने ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ है मैं एक
बग बाउंटीफुल टाइम नहीं हूं मैं फुल टाइम
हंटिंग नहीं कर सकता पॉसिबल नहीं है मेरे
लिए क्योंकि कंपनी को मैनेज करना होता है
एंड एक काम नहीं होते हैं मल्टीपल काम
करने होते हैं और एक अगर आप हंटर बनना
चाहते हैं तो आपको फुल फोकस करना पड़ेगा
बग हंटिंग पर बाकी काम को छोड़कर तब जाकर
आप कहीं सक्सेसफुल बनेंगे और आपको चांसेस
है जो आपको चीजें मिलनी स्टार्ट हो जाएंगी
अगर मैं फुल टाइम हंटिंग में गया तो पता
चलेगा कि मेरी कंपनी जो है ना जहां की है
वही रह गई वही रह जाएगी और बहुत मुश्किल
हो जाएगी थोड़ा सा मैनेजमेंट मुश्किल हो
जाता है बहुत दिमाग लगाना पड़ता है ठीक है
पटू
चाहिए ठीक है ठीक
है क्या बात है क्या बात है क्या बात है
मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशन
ठीक है पार्ट टू आएगा यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे वर्डप्रेस यूजर नेम्स
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
नेम्स इसने आइडेंटिफिकेशन
एक नादिया सिंह यूज़र नेम है फ्रूट
फॉरेस्ट है यहां पे एक स्टिक n7 w यह शायद
अ आई थिंक व डेटाबेस का होगा मेरे ख्याल
से फ्रूट फॉरेस्ट आ करके यूज़र नेम है एक
विक 81m करके एक यूज़र नेम है दिस इज़
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग राइट तो यह यूज़र नेम
नमरे भी आपका यहां पे हो चुका है एक्सएमएल
आरपीसी सर्विसेस आर इनेबल्ड अब यह एक्सएमए
आरपीसी को एक्सप्लॉयड कैसे करना है यह
आपको सीखना है क्या मुझे बता दीजिए एक एकए
आरपीसी को एक्सप्लोइट करने का इजी वे में
सीखना है क्या बता दीजिए एक
बार तो अगर आपको सीखना है तो मैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में एंड इसके साथ और भी चीजें जो है
आपको नेक्स्ट क्लास में लाकर दूंगा डिटेल
में थोड़ा और तो दो पार्ट में तो आनी इसकी
जरूरी है वड पस हंटिंग एक पार्ट में नहीं
हो पाएगा पॉसिबल नहीं है क्योंकि थोड़ा
डिटेल में है
ना ठीक है
ये ये थोड़ा सा टाइम लगेगा आपको इस टूल के
अंदर में यह बहुत ही बहुत ही डिटेल वो
करता है तो यहां पर भी हमारा काम ऑलमोस्ट
हो ही चुका है
[संगीत]
हम
चलिए यहां पे ऑलमोस्ट हो चुका है एंड इधर
भी आपके देखते हैं क्या रिजल्ट आ रहे है
यहां पे एक्ससीपी एक्सएमएल आरपीसी का
रिजल्ट आया हुआ है फिलहाल तो थोड़ा सा
देखो यहां पर टाइम लगेगा थोड़ा क्योंकि आप
रियल वेबसाइट प हंट कर रहे हो एंड ये रियल
टाइम में आपके सारी इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड
करता है तो आपको यहां थोड़ा सा समय लग
जाएगा ठीक है इस वाले रिजल्ट में तो आप ये
करते रहिएगा आप लोग यह कीजिएगा एंड इसमें
आपको रिजल्ट्स जरूर मिलेंगे सीएमएस मैप को
यूज़ कीजिएगा बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है
सीएमए मैप एंड डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन ये दोनों
ही बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है डब्ल्यूपी
स्कैन का बहुत ज्यादा फीचर है बहुत ज्यादा
फंक्शनैलिटीज है उसके जो ऑप्शंस हैं आप
उनको एक्सप्लोर थोड़ा कीजिएगा अलग-अलग
ऑप्शंस ट्राई कीजिएगा इनमेट करने का
एक्सप्लोइट करने अ मतलब अ वल्नरेबल
प्लगिंस डिटेक्ट करने का इनमेट करने का यह
सब चीजें आप कीजिएगा ठीक है उसके बाद जो
नेक्स्ट पार्ट
होगी सीएमएस अ सीएमएस मैप बस सीएमएस मैप
और वेबसाइट डाल दो आगे हो गया तो नेक्स्ट
जो पार्ट होगी उसमें हम डिटेल में थोड़ा अ
आर आरपीसी अ जो आपका एक्सएमएल आरपीसी है
इसके बारे में मेटा एक्सप्लोइट का यूज़
करेंगे थोड़ा हम इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें करने
के लिए एक्सप्लोइट्स वगैरह को लेके ठीक है
तो यहां पे हमारा यह काम तो हो चुका है
अपडेट वाला काम तो इसको हम बंद कर देते
हैं अब सिर्फ यह वाला बचा है तो यह वाला
अपना काम चल रहा है एंड इट्स टेकिंग लिटिल
बिट टाइम बट इट विल गिव यू गुड रिजल्ट्स
ठीक है तो यहां पर यूजर नेम मिल ग ये बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है सबसे ये देखो ये यूजर
नेम्स बहुत मस्त यूजर नेम ठीक
है सर 38 क्लास करने के बाद हम खुद को
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल का बंटा कर सकते बिल्कुल
कर सक बिल्कुल बोल सकते हैं बिल्कुल बोल
सकते हैं आप बग हंटर बन गए हैं ऑलरेडी
आपको बस ना दुनिया को दिखाने लिए वैलिड
बग्स फाइंड करनी है बस अब आपको मैं यह हो
रहा है तब तक इसको होने देते हैं मैं आपको
इसका एग्जांपल देता हूं देखो ऐसे ही नहीं
है जो हमारे मैं आपको दिखा भी देता हूं
आपको लग रहा होगा शायद
कुछ फोनिक्स पर आप चलते हैं एक्टिविटी पर
मैं चलता हूं
य तो देखो यहां पर मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं लेट
सी यह देखो हमारे स्टूडेंट्स को
ना वैलिड बक्स मिलते हैं ऐसा नहीं है कि
कुछ भी
मतलब वो है लाइक उनको मिलते हैं वैलिड
बक्स जैसे अभी रिसेंट में एक बंदे को मिला
था पक्ष करके बंदा है एक इसको यहां पे
देखो यहां पे इसने पोस्ट भी डाला हुआ है
इसको लेके यहां पे आप देखिए यहां पे ह्यूज
थैंक्स टू डिफर स्टब सिक्योरिटी आई एम
थ्रिल्ड टू शेयर दैट आई हैव सक्सेसफुली
फाउंड माय फर्स्ट बग एक्सेसेस वलने बिलिटी
ऑन ए वेबसाइट एंड सक्सेसफुली चें इट इनटू
एन अकाउंट टेकओवर लेबिलिटी तो इन्होंने
यहां पे किया है यहां पे स्क्रीनशॉट्स भी
डाले हैं कि एक डोमेन है यह डोमेन इंडिया
टाइम्स की है ठीक है क्योंकि इन्होंने
डोमेन को हाइड करने की कोशिश की है बट जब
मैंने देखा था तो यहां इनकी बॉब शट में
डोमेन जो है वो क्लियर विजिबल है गेट
रिक्वेस्ट जो जा रही है ऊपर में वो यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं कि economictimes.com
को जा रही है तो इन्होंने सारी जगह पे
हाइड की है बट बट स्टिल हर चीज छिपाया
नहीं है तो यहां पे हमें डोमेन मिल चुकी
है यहां पे ठीक है तो यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं इन्होंने एक्सस यहां पे फाइंड किया तो
ये ही हैज गिवन तो इस तरह से एक नहीं है
यार ऐसे-ऐसे बहुत सारे हैं लोग जिनको
वनबिल मिलती है एंड यहां पे अ जो है उनको
बाउंट भी मिली है लोगों को अ हॉल ऑफ फेम
मिला है लोगों को तो दे हैव गॉट ठीक है
उनको मिला है दे आर गेटिंग तो इसमें कोई
बड़ी चीज वो नहीं है तो आपको बस थोड़ा सा
वो करना है टाइम देना है
दैट्ची ब्रूट फोर्स वल्नरेबल ये वेबसाइट
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी ब्रूट फोर्स से वल्नरेबल
है अब हम इस पे ना एक्सएमएल आरपीसी ब्रूट
फोर्स करेंगे समझ में आ रहा यूजर नेम
अ एडमिन एडमिन एंड लाइट डेविल मतलब तीन
यूजर्स है तीन यूजर्स है या दो है एडमिन
एडमिन एंड लाइट डेविल यह दो है ठीक है
चलिए ऑटो कंप्लीट ऑफ है ठीक है चलिए कोई
बात नहीं डिफॉल्ट वर्डप्रेस फाइल्स यहां
पे अब इनमेट करके ट्राई करेगा कि जो फाइल
से तो इसमें टाइम लग जाएगा ठीक है ठीक है
कोई दिक्कत इसमें टाइम लग जाएगा आप इसको
कीजिएगा इसमें बहुत इंफो आएंगी ओके तो
थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर करना है आपको गा
एक्सप्लोर नहीं करेंगे तो फिर काम नहीं
चलेगा तो आज हमने बेसिकली क्या किया है
मैं आपको बता देता
हूं बेसिकली हमने आज किया क्या है
इंस्टॉल ओल्ड वल्नरेबल
वर्डप्रेस
वर्जन ऑन लोकल
होस्ट यह हमने किया दूसरा हमने किया
इंस्टॉल्ड एंड यूज डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन टू
स्कैन वर्डप्रेस
वेबसाइट टू
फाइंड वल्नरेबल
प्लग इनस या थीम्स तीसरा हमने क्या
किया
इंस्टॉल्ड सीएमएस
मैप
सॉफ्टवेयर
टू
फाइंड वल्नरेबल ऑन
अ वर्डप्रेस
वेबसाइट ये हमने यह हमने मेन मेन काम किया
ठीक है
अ सर प्रिविलेज एक्शन होगा तो वो भी तो
क्रिटिकल हां बिल्कुल क्रिटिकल होगा
बिल्कुल सर डि फोनिक्स बग हंटिंग
आप देख सकते हो कि वेबसाइट वल्नरेबल टू
एक्सएल आरपीसी ब्रूट फोर्स वनबिल ऑटो
कंप्लीट डिफॉल्ट वर्डप्रेस फाइल्स यहां पे
डिफॉल्ट वर्डप्रेस फाइल जो है इनकी जो है
वह आपको यहां पे देखने को मिल रही है तो
आप यहां पे देख सकते हैं नी एमसी क्रिस्टल
लाइसेंस redmp3
मिला हुआ है कुछ एरर्स आई है इसको इग्नोर
कर दीजिएगा ठीक है 31 32
पर तो ये चलता
जाएगा ठीक है सो सबको यह समझ में आया जो
चीजें अभी हुई हैं सिंपल वर्डप्रेस
हंटिंग में हमने आज की क्लास के लिए
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन यूज़ किया सीएमएस मैप
यूज़ किया लोकल सेटअप किया वर्डप्रेस का
एक वल्नरेबल सेटअप किया है
दैट्ची को पोस्ट करना है टैग करना है
टास्क क्या है आपको यूज एंड एक्सप्लोर
डब्ल्यूपी स्कैन टूल इन काली टू
फाइंड वल्नरेबल
प्लग इनस और थीम्स यह करना है दूसरा टास्क
क्या है
आपका यूज सीएमएस मैप टू फाइंड
डिफरेंट वल्नरेबल
एंड एक्सप्लोइट्स
इन वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट्स
इन वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट्स यह आपको कर लेनी
है तीसरा जो है यहां पर क्या करना
है रीड एंड एक्सप्लोर
अबाउट
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी ड
पीएपी xmlrpc.php के बारे में आपको यहां
पर पढ़ लेना है बस आपको यह काम करना है
ठीक है इतना काम आप सबसे हो जाएगा यह बता
दीजिए मुझे यह तीन टास्क है आप सब लोग कर
लेंगे यह तीन टास्क्स मुझे बताइए ये अगले
क्लास के पहले क्योंकि अगले क्लास में हम
इसका सेकंड पार्ट लेकर आएंगे जिसमें हम
एक्सएमएल आरपीसी मेटा एक्सप्लोइट्स एंड
कुछ और डिफरेंट चीजों थोड़ा थोड़ा सा
एडवांस हो जाएगा उसको हम कवर करने वाले
हैं तो एवरीवन विल डू दिस राइट बिना
एक्सप्लोर किए मैं आपका कुछ नहीं कर सकता
ना मैं आपको कुछ करवा सकता हूं ना मैं
आपको प्रो बना सकता हूं प्रो मैं तभी बना
सकता हूं जब आप भी एफर्ट देंगे अदर वाइज
मैं मेरी बस की बात नहीं है किसी भी
ट्रेनर के बस की बात नहीं नहीं हां निकाल
लो एसएस निकाल लो ठीक है हो जाएगा ना सब
सभी लोग बोलो हो जाएगा तभी यार कॉन्फिडेंस
आता है मुझे नहीं तो फिर क्या ही है सभी
लोग बोलो हो जाएगा तो कॉन्फिडेंस आएगा
मुझे एसएस ले लो जिसको लेनी
है यहां पर यह 99 पर हो चुका है बहुत
बढ़िया हो जाएगा ना बहुत बढ़िया
गुड चलिए अच्छी बात है हो जाएगा
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंड एथिकल हैकिंग में
क्या डिफरेंस है इस पर शॉर्ट्स ऑलरेडी बनी
हुई है देख लीजिए डिफर अकेडमी प तभी तो
बोला डिफर अकेडमी के वीडियोस को प्रॉपर्ली
कोई देख लेगा ना सारी सब सवाल का जवाब
है बेसिक सर बेसिक लेवल तक का बग बाउंट
सीखने में बेसिक लेवल बग बाउंट सीखने के
लिए तो दो-तीन महीने काफी है थोड़ा सा
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल जाना है छ महीने कम से कम
एक साल कम से कम इन्वेस्ट जब कर दिया
तुमने प्रॉपर्ली तो यू विल बी स्टार्टिंग
या आपको वन बटीज वैलिड बक्स मिलने शुरू हो
जाएंगे या उसके पहले भी हो जाएंगे ऐसा
नहीं है कु सी टाइम होंगे उसके पहले भी हो
सकते हैं बहुत सारे लोगों के एक दो महीनों
में भी हो जाते हैं वो आपके ऊपर डिपेंड
करता है टोटली है ना तो टोटली डिपेंड ऑन
यू गाइस ओके तो यहां पे चलिए तो ये आप
करके देखिएगा
दैट्ची जिएगा इंफोसेक बडी के ऊपर के बीच
एंड बग बाउटी बडी के बीच जो बग बाउटी में
इंटरेस्टेड हैं वेब पेन टेस्टिंग में
इंटरेस्टेड हैं तो आप उनके बीच ये शेयर कर
सकते हैं बहुत जल्दी आप सबको अगर नहीं पता
तो हम एक वीएपीएल
हैं यानी कि बग बाउंट नहीं ओनली ओनली वेब
पेन टेस्टिंग नहीं होगी उसमें वी एपीटीडी
असेसमेंट एंड पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग जिसमें
आपका वेब एपीआई एंड नेटवर्क पेन टेस्टिंग
तीनों इंक्लूड होगा जो आप रियल कंपनी में
जो जिस तरीके से काम होता है उसी तरीके का
और उसी लेवल की ट्रेनिंग स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं बहुत ही शानदार साथ में एक
खतरनाक इंटर्नशिप होगी जिसमें आपसे हम
इंटर्नशिप के अंदर में प्राइवेट
प्रोग्राम्स के ऊपर हंट करवाएंगे आपको वो
मेथड सिखाएंगे एंड हम खुद आपके साथ मिलके
हंट करेंगे तो बेसिकली एवरीथिंग विल बी
वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग तो उसका अपडेट जैसे
ही आएगा आपको पता चल जाएगा ठीक है भैया तो
अभी के लिए बस फिलहाल इतना ही एंड मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में तब तक के लिए गुड
बाय एंड गुड नाइट थैंक यू सो मच फॉर
जॉइनिंग एंड हैव अ गुड नाइट